Moin
Wo hab ich denn mein Handy?
Kegwait
wieder da
Handy gefunden
Gamepad danke für den Sub
Also schon mal was mit HashiCorp Vault gemacht. Ja was gemacht ist halt sehr
allgemein umfassend
Der Katzenzaun trinkt halt nicht. Warum?
Ja wie findest du das Tool? Ich würde mal sagen es ist das beste für diesen Bereich was es gibt. Auf der Arbeit haben wir was anderes
Ich sage jetzt nicht was, aber es ist nicht
Vault. Es ist so ähnlich
Nur mit dem Unterschied und das ist wie bei vielen Tools. Ich mach mal kurz die Katze aus und das ist weil bei vielen Tools
die
Verbreitung hat halt auch
wie soll ich sagen
einen gewissen Vorteil. Wenn was verbreitet ist gibt es für
Sonderfälle schon oftmals fertige Lösungen. Du kannst viele Sachen nachgucken. Es ist oftmals auch relativ gut
sagen wir mal für die meisten Standardsachen geeignet. Sonst wäre es nicht so viel verbreitet
Das kenne ich nicht
Ja und deswegen wäre es mir auf der Arbeit lieber wir hätten auch Vault. Haben wir aber nicht
Wir haben was anderes. Oh moin Leute
Ich wollte die Uhr ausziehen
Gucken ob meine App gesynct hat. Ja ja war ich gerade
Ich bin heute eine mittellange Runde gelaufen. Ich bin heute
Ich glaube 7,5 Kilometer oder so
Erst mal kurz
kurz in die App gucken
Die App zeigt wieder übelsten Schwachsinn an. Alter wie wäre es mit Syncen
Sync Champ
Echt ich wusste gar nicht dass es so teuer ist
Ich dachte man kann Vault einfach so inszenieren. Man braucht da doch gar keine großartige Lizenz für oder?
Was kann denn die Enterprise Version?
So viel Geld?
Viel besseres?
Oh meine Garmin App meint ich war sehr productive diese Woche
Weiß ich nicht ich bin schneller als vorher also ja wahrscheinlich aber
Ich renne jetzt einfach schneller. Ich renne immer so mit um die 160 Puls die Runde. Das ist einfach am angenehmsten
Morgen mündliches Abi Biologie. Ja GLHF
Wieso geht Twitch immer auf 160p?
Das ist einfach am angenehmsten. Morgen mündliches Abi Biologie. Ja GLHF. Wieso geht Twitch immer auf 160p?
Das macht man mit Twitch auch manchmal wenn ich's auf automatisch stehen habe warum weiß ich auch nicht
Heute hatte ich wieder genau das gleiche
159 Puls
612 pro Kilometer und 7,39 Kilometer
Also Semi
semi schnell
Aber man soll es ja nicht immer übertreiben ich bin die letzten tage
bin ich viel Fahrrad gefahren wie jetzt?
habe letzten zwei tage bin ich
viel Fahrrad gefahren, weil ich wollte
mein neues Fahrrad ein bisschen austesten. Ich habe jetzt
ja ein neues.
Kam am Freitag an.
Alter, dein Mund schmeckt übelst nach Salz, ey.
Ich bin immer noch
ein bisschen geschwitzt.
Renn nicht, du sollst mal kurz was trinken, ey.
So.
Wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Ja, genau. Am Freitag kam das Fahrrad an.
Und
bin ich am Samstag
bin ich am Freitag
eine ordentliche Runde
gefahren.
Es war nur eine Stunde 15, aber dafür
relativ schnell und relativ
ordentlich reingetreten, gleich mal um zu gucken, wie es läuft.
Gestern auch nochmal.
Und heute Morgen dann
knapp 7,5 Kilometer gerannt.
Eigentlich wollte ich heute Mittag noch mal
eine Runde Fahrrad fahren, einfach weil es Bock macht,
ein schönes Wetter ist und ich mein neues
Fahrrad ein bisschen
einfahren muss.
Aber wenn ich jetzt so gucke,
ist das Wetter
glaube ich
doch nicht so geil.
Ich glaube, die müssten mal AI-basierte
Wettervorhersage
machen, weil gestern
war quasi mehr oder weniger
den ganzen Tag heute
schönes Wetter
und jetzt ist
halt Wolken. So.
Keine Ahnung, wie die sich da so
echt so krass vertun, ey.
Ist halt ein Riesenunterschied.
Die Wettervorhersage ist doch mehr oder eher
anscheinend nicht genug AI.
Heute war bis 17 Uhr schön, aber
es ist schon wieder schönes Wetter, Sonnenschein.
Aber wenn ich jetzt...
Es ist sogar in der Vorschau immer noch, witzigerweise.
Und wenn ich jetzt
umschalte auf heute, ist halt
den ganzen Tag wolke ich mit
vielleicht ab und zu mal ein bisschen Sonne.
Solange es nicht regnet.
Ja, aber es macht mit Sonne deutlich mehr Spaß zu fahren.
Ja, hatte ich auch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sieht's
da eigentlich mit Nintendo aus?
Ich hatte beides drauf.
Ich hatte Yuzu drauf und ich hatte...
Wie heißt das andere?
Ryu irgendwas?
Ryu...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab beides drauf.
Manches lief mit dem einen besser, manches mit dem...
Ja, ja, genau.
Eine lief mit dem besser, andere mit dem.
Ähm...
Wie sieht's denn da jetzt mit Nintendo und Yuzu aus?
Haben die da irgendwie... Gab's da was Neues?
Selbstverständlich.
Ich mein, was anderes...
Wer macht denn auch schon was anderes?
Wirklich?
Tatsächlich, das ist weg?
Das hat doch hundertpro irgendjemand
schon geforkt, oder?
Das hat doch hundertpro schon jemand geforkt.
Hat irgendwas ausgebaut
und nennt es jetzt anders.
Yuzu heißt es jetzt? Wirklich?
Ja, das ist aber
egal, ob es ganz viele Seiten gibt,
die das zum Download anbieten. Das Eigentliche
ist die Weiterentwicklung. Die
ist ja wichtig. Das Ding ist weit davon entfernt
perfekt zu funktionieren.
Das ist halt das Ding.
Da brauchst du schon ein offizielles Repo.
Ein legales offizielles Repo.
Ähm...
Das war der Nintendo DS
Emulator, gell?
Ja, aber die meisten Leute, die das Ding verwenden, sind nicht in der Lage
an nem Emulator gescheit
mitzuwirken.
Ich geh davon aus, dass
das Projekt relativ schnell wieder geben wird auf
GitHub.
Vielleicht etwas legalerer Form.
Vielleicht die
Parts entfernt, die
strittig waren.
Weil nen Emulator zu entwickeln
an sich ist ja nicht verboten.
Teile, die geschützt sind,
damit zu distributen und sowas, das ist verboten.
Übrigens, Leute, ich hab's jetzt
auf der Arbeit geschafft.
Unser Spanier, der hat letztens
seinen letzten Arbeitstag gehabt bei uns.
Und ich hab ihn an seinem letzten Tag gefragt,
ob er El Risitas kennt.
Und natürlich kannte er
El Risitas.
Wusste auch, dass der in irgendeiner Talkshow bekannt geworden ist.
Ich wollte einfach von dem wissen,
wie bekannt ist der Typ eigentlich in Spanien?
Das konnte er mir nicht so richtig
beantworten.
Aber er kennt's
und er meinte,
es ist traurig,
dass...
Das ist eigentlich voll die Boomer-Antwort, wenn man's mal so will.
Er meinte, es ist traurig, dass sowas
heutzutage das ist, wofür Spanier
in Spanien bekannt ist.
Dabei finde ich das
eigentlich doch gut. Das ist doch was, was die Leute zum
Lachen bringt. Wo ist das Problem dabei?
Ja, was Nintendo will
und wo Nintendo am Ende recht
bekommt, sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Wenn es jetzt...
Wenn ich als Privatperson da jetzt irgendwie
mich mit Nintendo rumärgern müsste, das würde ich auch nicht machen.
Ja, gibt Schlimmeres, oder?
Gibt Schlimmeres.
Ich geh davon aus, dass wir das relativ schnell
sehen werden, das Projekt.
In irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Ne, so hat er das nicht gesagt.
Der hat sinngemäß
sowas gesagt. Ja, das ist halt
das...
Er findet's traurig, dass das
das ist, was sie heutzutage
oder dass es solche Sachen sind, die sie heute irgendwie
quasi in die Welt exportieren.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist er auch einfach ein bisschen...
Vielleicht mag er das auch nicht.
Kein Schlimmer.
Ja, also
wir werden dann aber keinen Emulator auf Github
veröffentlichen.
Ich geh davon aus, dass es das bald wieder
geben wird. Ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass es dann so Kombinationen geben
wird, wie der Source-Code ist auf Github,
aber Bills davon
gibt es nicht vom gleichen Projekt,
sondern nur von anderen.
Und irgendwie...
Da wird's garantiert
Wege finden.
Betreust du eigentlich wieder Azubis im neuen Laden?
Ne, wir haben auch wenig...
Wir haben gar nicht so wenig Azubis, aber...
Ich persönlich hab meinen Zweifel, wie viel die lernen
dort als Azubis, weil die sind permanent
damit beschäftigt, durch alle möglichen
Abteilungen zu tingeln und sich das ein oder andere
anzugucken.
So wirklich tiefgreifend Ahnung
hast du davon eigentlich am Ende nicht.
Die...
Ich denke, das liegt daran, dass
die Firma eher Azubis
ausbildet, um sich...
Also die bildet die Azubis für
genau diese Firma aus und nicht
als guten
Fisi.
Als guten Fisi müsstest du beispielsweise
schon mal ein bisschen rumgucken
oder auch als Anwendungsentwickler,
was ist denn, was dir gefällt,
aber dann musst du mindestens zwei Jahre von deiner
Ausbildung dort sein
und dich damit schon tiefgreifend beschäftigen.
Du kannst nicht mal
5 Wochen
Linux machen, 5 Wochen Windows machen,
5 Wochen Netzwerk machen,
5 Wochen Mainframe machen,
5 Wochen Cloud-Geschichten machen...
Das funktioniert nicht gescheit.
Da hast du am Ende ein bisschen Überblick, du kennst dich super in den
der Firma aus, du kennst dich auch super aus,
wie der Laden tickt, aber von der
Technik hast du am Ende keinen Plan.
Also, die machen das sicherlich gut,
Nachwuchskräfte
heranzuzüchten für exakt diese
Firma, weil die kennen sich in der Firma
und den Workflows und drum herum alles wunderbar
aus.
Aber...
Was die halt nicht... Was nicht
am Ende rauskommt, ist technisch gut versierte
Fisis und Anwendungsentwickler.
Du bist Anwendungsentwickler?
Ja gut,
das ist natürlich kacke.
Man sollte schon erwarten,
dass man in der Ausbildung als Anwendungsentwickler
auch ein bisschen was mit Softwareentwicklung und
Programmieren zu tun hat, weil ansonsten...
Warum wirst du Anwendungsentwickler?
Die Firma muss ja
eine Azubi-Stelle für
Anwendungsentwickler ausgeschrieben haben,
die du bekommst, also die müssen ja schon
was in der Richtung zu tun haben.
Ja, das läuft... Also wie gesagt, bei uns
ich glaube, das läuft
für die Firma gut, weil die
Nachwuchskräfte ausbilden, die sich halt
super in der Firma auskennen,
aber da kommen am Ende
keine guten Fisis bei raus.
Gibt es eigentlich einen Emulator, der gut
Multiplayer kann? Du meinst für die Switch? Keine Ahnung.
Wie groß hatte ich ausprobiert?
Für ältere Konsolen
gibt's das.
Also, für sowas wie Super Nintendo
und so, kannst du
Spiele online spielen, die früher
nur mit Splitscreen
und...
oder nicht nur Splitscreen.
Multi-Input-Controller.
Das Wichtigste ist,
dass du die Abschlussprüfung packst
und dazu musst du gar nicht so viel Ahnung haben.
Dazu musst du alte Abschlussprüfungen
machen und wissen, wie die IHK
fragt und was die IHK hören will.
Das ist eigentlich das Schwierige an der Abschlussprüfung.
Gar nicht so sehr, dass man großartig Ahnung
haben muss. Man schafft die Abschlussprüfung zum
Fachinformatiker auch ohne Ahnung zu
haben.
Das klingt jetzt doof,
ist aber so.
Du kannst das schaffen, komplett planlos,
sofern du checkst, wie die IHK Fragen stellen
und was die hören wollen.
Das Fachinformatiker-Buch ist ja, glaube ich,
nicht mehr zugelassen zur Abschlussprüfung.
Das war auch so eine Gelddruckmaschine
für diesen Verlag,
dass die
das einzig zugelassene Prüfungsbuch
hatten.
Hast du schon... Klar, haben wir schon mal
vor zwei Wochen geguckt.
Oder gibt es einen zweiten Teil
schon?
Zum Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Immerhin ist er konsequent.
Sagt der Polizei, sie sollen
mal ihren Umweltschild sauber machen
und wenn sein Fahrrad umkippt, ruft er auch
die Polizei an.
Was dir die Ausbildung bringt?
Dass du eine Ausbildung fertig hast, bringt dir das.
Dass du danach einen Job findest,
bringt dir das.
Du wirst natürlich Schwierigkeiten haben,
wenn du gar keinen Plan hast.
Aber ganz
ehrlich, ich habe das meiste auch...
Also die wichtigsten Sachen habe ich eh für mich gelernt
und nicht auf der Arbeit.
Am Ende hat es immer auf der Arbeit was gebracht,
wobei ich auch sehr viele Sachen gelernt
habe, die
ich dann nicht gebraucht habe, weil es mich einfach
persönlich interessiert hat.
Ja klar, natürlich will sie nicht ordentlich ausbilden,
aber wenn das nicht der Fall ist,
was ist denn... Was ist besser?
Sagen wir mal so.
Nichts beigebracht kriegen,
sich mit dem zu...
Dementsprechend sich privat mit dem zu beschäftigen,
ob man Bock hat und die Abschlussprüfung zu packen
oder nichts beigebracht zu kriegen,
nichts zu machen und die Abschlussprüfung
nicht zu packen.
Das ist doch mit Sicherheit besser.
Du sagst
Scheiß auf den Laden, ich suche mir danach was
Neues, wenn es Kacke ist.
Aber das geht nur, wenn du eine Abschlussprüfung gepackt hast.
Natürlich müssten die dich ausbilden, aber
anscheinend machen sie es ja nicht.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was du schon unternommen hast.
Es gibt ja
zumindest bei größeren Laden auch offizielle
Beauftragte für
Ausbildung.
Bei denen kann man ja durchaus mal ansprechen,
dass du den Eindruck hast,
dass ich da...
Dein Kenntnisstand
nicht dem entspricht,
wie lange du schon in der Ausbildung bist,
deiner Meinung nach.
Und dass du gerne mehr Sachen machen würdest.
Mal gucken, was die da sagen.
Aber ansonsten gibt es auch viele Scheißläden.
Da ist das Beste, was du machen kannst,
dir privat das angucken, worauf du Bock hast,
und eben die
Abschlussprüfung schaffen,
dass du da weg kannst.
Was?
So, Arch, by the way.
Ich mach mal kurz meine VM an
und ne Runde Package-Updates.
Weil Arch Linux...
Nein, nein, ich mach nicht 17.5
Update.
17.5 ist verbuggt.
AF.
Übrigens, jetzt, wo ich gestern
und vorgestern wieder ein bisschen Fahrrad gefahren bin
mit dem neuen Rad,
ist mir immer wieder aufgefallen,
wie beschissen
die Straßen hier
in der Gegend, oder wahrscheinlich in Deutschland
allgemein sind, zum Fahrradfahren.
Also, mehrere Sachen.
Erstens, die Fahrradwege sind
oftmals in unterirdisch schlechtem
Zustand. Also sie sind
durchzogen mit Wurzeln und
kaputtem Asphalt und alles.
Wisst ihr, ich hab
mich früher immer aufgeregt da drüber, wo ich
noch nicht selbst Fahrrad gefahren bin.
Ich hab mich immer drüber aufgeregt, was die ganzen
Fahrradfahrer eigentlich auf der Straße machen,
wenn doch direkt daneben ein
Fahrradweg ist.
Jetzt weiß ich's. Die fahren auf der Straße,
weil du auf den Fahrradwegen nicht gescheit fahren kannst.
Ohne dass dir der Arsch blutet.
Weil du so durch
geschüttelt wirst die ganze Zeit.
Ich komm aus der
Nähe von Frankfurt.
Zwischen Frankfurt und Hanau.
Also in Frankfurt selbst,
gerade am Main unten sind die Fahrradwege nice,
aber ein bisschen draußen ist halt richtig beschissen.
Und
was mir halt auch
gestern wieder aufgefallen ist,
du kannst eigentlich
gar nicht
wirklich risikofrei, wie soll man
das sagen, fahren.
Du bist immer
komplett ausgeliefert dem,
dass
die Autofahrer aufpassen im Endeffekt.
Also,
zum Beispiel bin ich gestern
aus einer Straße raus gefahren.
Ich fahr ja immer absichtlich nicht durch Straßen,
also nicht dort wo Autos fahren.
Ich fahr ein bisschen
Waldwege oder Fahrradwege
oder irgendwas da wo, also ich fahr
ungern dort wo Autos sind.
Witzigerweise ist es natürlich da wo Autos
sind, wurde ich auch umgefahren.
Aber das Ding ist,
ich bin gestern
aus einer Straße raus gefahren
und das ist im Endeffekt
das ist nicht
überschaubar als
Fahrradfahrer.
Du hast von links
eine Straße die kommt, du hast von rechts
eine Straße, also
du hast geradeaus eine Straße, von links kann einer kommen,
von rechts kann einer kommen. Theoretisch
können die dich von hinten überholen,
weil das denen ja egal ist, ob du da stehst.
Von links schräg
kommt eine Straße noch und von rechts schräg
kommt eine. Das sind quasi 1, 2, 3,
4, 5,
also mit der Straße auf der du draufstehst,
5 Straßen, wo Autos rauskommen.
Und die sind,
die gehen nicht irgendwie im rechten Winkel
irgendwie gescheit aufeinander, was ja bei 5 Straßen
auch nicht geht, sondern so schräg
und die Ausfahrt ist auch so
so breit und langgezogen,
du siehst gar nichts.
Und wenn du ganz vorne stehst,
damit du in alle Richtungen
gucken kannst,
stehst du im Endeffekt schon
schräg auf dem
Überweg, der da ist
und
dadurch, dass die Ausfahrten so breit sind,
kommst du dir schon fast vor,
als stehst du mitten auf der Kreuzung.
Das ist super beschissen gemacht, Alter.
Das wirklich das sicherste
ist da echt, du fährst einfach
ein Stückchen nach rechts,
steigst ab
und
guckst dann an der Straße und rennst
mit dem Fahrrad so über die Straße und
steigst auf der anderen Seite wieder auf.
Das, es ist echt
nicht durchblickbar.
Und du bist
permanent darauf angewiesen,
dass die Autofahrer
aufpassen,
was halt viele nicht machen.
Also deswegen,
ich vermeide alle Straßen, wo
irgendwie Autos fahren, wenn es nicht irgendwie geht.
Also die beschissenste Stelle an der Route,
die ich fahre, ist eigentlich immer
von dort, wo ich wohne, rein und raus.
Also die paar
Meter durch den Ort,
bis ich da ein bisschen raus bin.
Oft ist es für Autofahrer
genauso schlecht.
Das ist für mich aber noch schlechter,
wenn es für Autofahrer, also ne,
weil ich ziehe auf jeden Fall den Kürzeren.
Ist das
UI eigentlich standardmäßig schon
vorinstalliert? Nein.
Außerdem gibt es nicht das UI.
Das ist I3.
X11
Xorg mit I3.
Falls du die Config brauchst,
oder es interessiert, wie ich das
configured habe, dann kannst
du auf GitHub hier gucken.
Macht eigentlich der Fiat Champ.
Gibt es da neue Issues?
Alles perfekt.
Habe ich jetzt hier alles updated?
Ja.
Es ist richtig scheiße, da Fahrrad zu fahren.
Also ganz ehrlich, so
unangenehm das ist, ich glaube
das Sicherste ist, und das werde ich in Zukunft auch machen,
an diesen unübersichtlichen
Dingern, ich fahre einfach
an die Seite,
steige ab, schiebe das
Fahrrad auf den Gehweg,
gucke vorne, ob was
kommt, schiebe das Fahrrad über die
Gas, und fahre auf der anderen Seite
weiter, weil da blickst du nicht
durch.
So.
Ach, by the way.
Warum lädt das jetzt nicht?
Ah, der Coffee Champ ist am Start.
Also ich bin gestern,
äh nicht gestern, vorgestern,
Max FPS,
Twitter,
ich bin gestern,
oh man, alter,
Elon, please!
Warum ist Twitter so unusable?
Warum ist Twitter
so unusable geworden?
So, also, das ist meine
Einweihungsrunde gewesen fürs neue
Fahrrad. Freitag ist das gekommen,
und da bin ich quasi
direkt nach
der Arbeit, bin ich
Stunde 15 hier
eine Runde gefahren.
Es war übelst Gegenwind,
und
Kassi Gea am Start, Familie mit
Kindern am Start, ich musste also laufen, bremsen,
und trotzdem
war ich noch ungefähr 2 kmh
die gleiche Strecke schneller als sonst.
Also als letztes Jahr.
Also man sieht,
man sieht die
im Winter
im Winter auf dem Smart Trainer
hocken, mit meinem
ollen Fahrrad, was heißt mit meinem alten,
das alte ist ja auch erst ein halbes Jahr alt, aber halt
kaputt,
hat sich gelohnt, ja.
Ich hab jetzt auch eine viel höhere durchschnittliche Herzfrequenz
gepackt,
weil mir die Beine nicht mehr so wehtun.
Vorher hatte ich immer 130
oder sowas, weil mir die Beine sofort gebrannt
haben, wenn ich ein bisschen Gas
gegeben hab. Aber jetzt ging's
echt ganz gut.
Nee, mach ich nicht.
Mach ich nicht, mach ich nicht.
Da müsste ich, ja,
ich hab mir das überlegt.
Ich werde nicht mit dem Fahrrad
auf die Arbeit fahren und nicht mit dem, ich wollte ja
eigentlich, ne? Ich werde nicht mit dem Fahrrad
auf die Arbeit fahren und nicht zurück, weil
mein Fahrrad ist teuer, mein Fahrrad hat einen
Carbonrahmen und ich hab keinen Bock, dass
das irgendwie verkratzt oder Leute irgendwie
mit irgendwas dagegen hauen aus versehen
in der Bahn und sonst was.
Es ist zwar morgen jetzt nicht,
wenn ich fahre, nicht super brechend voll,
aber voll genug. Und ich
muss dann in die Bahn mit dem Fahrrad und dann muss
ich quasi aus dem Hauptbahnhof raus
und das bei uns
auf der Arbeit abstellen. Dort gibt's
halt extra Fahrradraum. Was ich mir jetzt überlegt
habe ist, ich kaufe mir noch
ein Alu-E-Bike.
Und
damit komme ich
dann auch heim, wenn ich mal gar keinen Bock habe.
Und ich komme theoretisch auch
hin, keck Alu, und ich komme
theoretisch auch hin
morgens, wenn ich
keinen Bock habe und scheiß
Wetter ist und so.
Ich glaube, das werde ich machen.
Ich kaufe mir quasi noch eins mit Motor
und stabil
und ausgerüstet
mit
Sonnenlichtern und
Schutzblechen, falls es spritzt
und sowas.
Ich glaube, ich kaufe mir noch ein zweites für
nach Frankfurt fahren.
Es sind ungefähr 28,
30 Kilometer,
ja, sagen wir mal 28 Kilometer
so circa
von mir
dorthin, wo ich arbeite.
Das ist eine leise Strecke.
Dann ist man
schön wach morgens.
Ja, bieten sie an, aber mache ich nicht.
Ich habe da keinen Bock, irgendwas an der Backe zu haben.
Ich kaufe mir doch was
Gutes.
Ich habe gerade wieder Bereitschaft dieses Wochenende.
Wo habe ich mein Bereitschaftshandy? Mal gucken,
ob das was gewesen ist. Nee, ist nichts gewesen.
Und alleine schon,
das ist halt echt der Witz,
wenn du dir überlegst, zweimal
Wochenende Bereitschaft gemacht, aber sagen wir mal,
okay, nee, nicht ganz, das stimmt nicht.
Ich muss ja noch Steuern bezahlen, was ziemlich sackt.
Sagen wir mal, sechsmal
Bereitschaft
gemacht, Wochenende
kann ich mir das Fahrrad kaufen.
Und das ist
jetzt schon mit Steuern abgezogen.
Mit 50% Steuern gerechnet, soviel.
Das ist ja gar nicht, also realistisch sagen wir mal,
vier bis fünfmal, vier bis fünfmal
Bereitschaft am Wochenende machen, dann kann ich mir das E-Bike
kaufen. Easy.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Was macht der
Bereitschaftschamp?
Der funktioniert, den verwende ich seit ein paar Wochen schon.
Seitdem wir hier gebastelt haben im Stream.
Ja.
Alter, ich kann ja immer schreiben, Wobblords.
Den verwende ich schon seit hier,
seitdem wir da geproggert
haben im Stream.
Der sticht mich automatisch ein und aus, was
Bereitschaft angeht.
Der läuft auch jetzt im Hintergrund
auf meiner
Linux VM auf der Arbeit.
Und der wird mich Montagmorgen um 7 Uhr
ausstechen. Äh, 7 Uhr
30.
8 Uhr?
8 Uhr 30.
Der Einzige, der mich überholt hat hier auf meiner Runde,
äh,
nicht mal, wo ich's hab hier.
Der Einzige, der mich hier auf meiner
Testfahrt überholt hat mit dem
neuen Fahrrad, war tatsächlich ein
Fahrradkurier.
Die sind krass drauf, die Typen,
die haben Übung.
Hattest du schon mal einen Fall von Bereitschaft?
Jaja, schon öfters.
Kommt ab und zu mal vor.
Aber selten. Es kommt so selten vor,
dass ich
es immer noch
vorziehe, Bereitschaft zu haben
versus keine Bereitschaft zu haben.
Weil der, das Verhältnis
von Aufwand zu Geld
immer noch positiv
überwiegt, ja.
Ein Wochenende war wirklich nervig.
Das war letztes Jahr im Ende
November, letztes Jahr Ende November.
Da hat mich erst Samstags
morgens irgendjemand angerufen.
Da war dann auch wirklich was kaputt.
Da hat irgendein Windows-
Sync nicht funktioniert.
Habe ich eigentlich gar nichts mit zu tun.
Ich kümmere mich ja auch nach wie vor hauptsächlich
um Linux-Zeug.
Aber da hat irgendwelche Windows-Sachen
nicht richtig gesynct, was dann dazu geführt hat,
dass irgendwelche Berechtigungen nicht gestimmt haben.
Was dann dazu geführt hat, dass die auf irgendwelche
Linux-Systeme was nicht machen konnten.
Da war ich bestimmt eine Stunde zu gange.
Die ich übrigens nie abgerechnet habe,
die Stunde, weil
wenn ich eintragen würde
in unserer Zeiterfassung
ich habe eine Stunde gearbeitet
am Samstag, dann kriege ich Zeit
gut geschrieben, aber ich habe genug Zeit.
Ich bevorzuge lieber das Geld
zu bekommen.
Ich habe die gar nicht eingetragen.
So und dann, das gleiche Wochenende
war dann nachts
oder morgens, Sonntag morgens
kam dann noch irgendeine Monitoring-Meldung.
Dass datenbankmäßig
was kaputt ist.
Da dachte ich erst
das ist einfach
nur eine
falsche Monitormeldung.
Weil da kam sinngemäß sowas wie
Monitoring Agent
empfängt keine Daten mehr.
Habe ich mich eingeloggt
auf den Server, Server lief
sah gut aus, habe ich mir gedacht ey
Monitoring hat Probleme.
Habe ich gesagt hier
bitte Montag Frühschicht drum kümmern
Server ist da, alles gut.
Und dann Sonntag Mittag habe ich mir gedacht
ey guckst du nochmal drauf
und dann ist mir aufgefallen, ne das ist eine Datenbankkiste
auf der die Datenbank wirklich kaputt ist.
Und dadurch das die Datenbank kaputt ist
hing der Monitoring Agent
und der Monitoring Agent
hing, weil irgendjemand einen
synchronen Datenbankabfragecheck
programmiert hat.
Richtig, richtig pepega.
Also sprich, wenn die Datenbank kaputt geht
dann hängt der Monitoring Check für immer
und dann kackt der Monitoring Agent ab.
Also weiß nicht
schlechter gehts kaum noch.
Ich meine hätte auch ich sein können der das
gebaut hat, ja aber hat wahrscheinlich nie
einer ausprobiert.
Deswegen hat man gar nicht mitbekommen das die
Datenbank kaputt ist, sondern es kam nur
eine Meldung Monitoring Agent kaputt.
Halt eigentlich ziemlicher Fail.
Und da habe ich dann abends noch
denjenigen erreicht der für diese
Datenbank zuständig ist
und der hat gesagt ey weißt was
lass einfach neu starten und gut ist.
Habe ich die Datenbank
neu gestartet und dann
ging es wieder.
Wir haben im Team einer der immer über alles meckern muss
der war natürlich der Meinung Datenbank
neu starten war keine gute Idee weil
ach keine Ahnung.
Kennt ihr das
es gibt Leute die müssen immer meckern.
Moin.
Es gibt Leute die müssen immer meckern.
Was auch
witzig ist, letztens
letztens bei uns im Team Daily
müsst ihr mir mal sagen
Leute ob ihr auch so Kollegen
habt oder so Leute kennt.
Letztens bei uns im Team Meeting
habe ich gesagt hier sagt mal
wir sind jetzt ja fertig
aber ich wollte euch mal was fragen.
Habt ihr auch alle so viele Meetings?
Habe ich mal
meinen Kalender kurz gescreenshot
habe gesagt hier ich habe jetzt mal ausgerechnet
es ist kein Witz Leute.
Ich habe ausgerechnet letzte Woche
ich arbeite ja nur 4 Tage
letzte Woche hatte ich 8 Stunden
die gesamte Woche zum Arbeiten.
Ich habe die Mittagspause schon abgezogen.
8 Stunden der Rest war Meeting.
Also ich habe jetzt ohne Scheiß
von 4 Tagen
also könnte man quasi sagen
ja
3 Viertel habe ich gemietet.
75%
75% Meeting Anteil. Nice oder?
So und
da habe ich gesagt Leute habt ihr das auch?
Und da meinen alle oh ja
ist bei uns auch vielleicht teilweise nicht ganz so krass
wie die Woche aber
haben wir auch und
dann haben wir
ein bisschen drüber geredet und ich habe so
3-4 Sätze mit einem anderen Kollege ausgedacht.
Und dann kommt dann unser Meckerer
wieder um die Ecke und meint
ja ich gehe dann mal oder irgendwie
sowas in der Richtung
ihr könnt euch ja danach weiter drüber
unterhalten.
Da hat er so gemacht
er fühlt sich ausgegrenzt
so von dieser Diskussion.
Da habe ich schon gedacht hä?
Was ist jetzt los?
Weil ansonsten kann der gleiche Typ
10 Minuten Monologe halten
ohne dass es ihn irgendwie juckt dass er
10 Minuten der einzige ist der was erzählt
und
da habe ich mich ein bisschen aufgeregt und
dann haben wir ihn
ein bisschen geflamed
und dann war schlechte Stimmung so
Kennt ihr so Leute
die laufen irgendwie nerven müssen
mit irgendwas
so grundlos
es ist wirklich anstrengend ja
aber was man daran auch merkt
und das finde ich eigentlich ganz witzig
was man daran auch merkt erstens bin ich deutlich
entspannter was das angeht als früher
ich meine mich regt es immer noch auf
aber
ich raste dann nicht mehr aus
und
krieg mich übelst auf
ich reg mich dann mal kurz auf
hier in der Runde dann ist gut
also ich bin da deutlich entspannter geworden
was das angeht
und was man auch daran merkt
ist
ich bin jetzt fast ein Jahr dort
und es gibt halt Sachen die einen einfach nerven
was man daran merkt ist
sobald es genug Sachen gibt die einen nerven
merkt man
dass so diese Einarbeitungsphase
Eingewöhnungsphase vorbei ist
weil am Anfang wenn man irgendwo neu ist
findet man das in der Regel eigentlich toll
und so negative Sachen merkt man gar nicht
sobald man
aber merkt okay es gibt genug Dinger
die dir so spontan einfallen die dir auf den Sack gehen
dann weißt du okay du bist angekommen
alles alltagsmäßig passt
aber verhältnismäßig muss ich immer noch sagen
es nervt mich deutlich weniger als beim
alten Laden und vor allem
viel also ganz andere
und viel unwichtigere
Sachen die mich nerven als beim alten Laden
ja in meinem Team
finde ich alle finde ich alle nice außer halt
wie gesagt unser Spezialmeckerer
der aber überall was zu meckern hat
aber es ist halt ein bisschen schade insofern
weil immer weißt du wisst ihr wenn
der eine dabei hast der die ganze Zeit rummecker
das zieht die anderen Leute dann auch
immer runter so die merkst du direkt
die haben gar keinen Bock mehr irgendwie weiter
zu machen was ist das
unwichtigste worüber du dich gerne
oh da muss ich mir Gedanken machen da gibt es bestimmt sehr viel
C++ ja
ja das stimmt
ich reg mich auch
gern auf über Leute die sich über unsinnige
Sachen aufregen
das ist ja vielleicht noch unsinniger
da müsste ich mir mehr Gedanken drüber
machen aber es gibt sicherlich
einiges mich regt vieles
auf
und vieles davon ist sehr unwichtig
was mich zum Beispiel
nervt ist und das ist super unwichtig
jetzt mal Gaming Aspekt
was mich übelst
abfuckt sind Leute
die ein Spiel seit über
20 Jahren spielen
aber die absoluten Basics nicht
geschissen bekommen
das regt mich immer auf
extrem regt mich das auf
ich bin immer am flamen
Beispiel okay
nicht LOL
naja gut LOL und Dota
ist ja nur
Toxic Games
games ever
wobei ehrlich gesagt Overwatch Ranked
auch schon ganz schön heftig war
Beispiel
ich nehme mal das als Beispiel
was mich gestern aufgeregt hat
ich spiele ja Dark Age of
Camelot seit 2002
und ich spiele das
aktuell auch immer wieder auf dem Freeshot
und aktuell auch auf dem Freeshot
und das ist
ein MMO
ein PvP fokussiertes MMO
du kannst natürlich auch Monster kloppen oder so aber
der Kern des Games ist PvP
fokussiertes
PvP fokussiertes MMO
so und
dort hat man 8er Gruppen
also nicht so wie heute klassisch
in MMOs 5er Gruppen 8er Gruppen
was ich sehr nice finde
weil das bietet enorm viele Möglichkeiten
wie man Gruppen bauen kann
und mehr Variationen irgendwie
dafür brauchst du natürlich auch
8 Leute
8 Leute zusammen bekommen ist um ein Vielfaches schwieriger
als 5 Leute zusammen zu bekommen
und dementsprechend
invited man halt immer auch mal random Leute
und du brauchst in dem Game so ein paar Sachen
dass du gescheit PvP spielen kannst
zum Beispiel brauchst du eine Klasse
die dein
Runspeed erhöht
weil sonst bist du zu langsam und wirst von allem abgefarmt
weil dich alle erwischen
du brauchst eine Klasse die den Runspeed erhöht
und da habe ich
gestern random einen eingeladen
und der war immer komplett
am Arsch der Welt
der hat einen Gegner gesehen
und ist dann einfach mal
obwohl wir gar nicht zu den Gegnern hingelaufen sind
ist dann einfach mal 2 Minuten den Gegnern hinterher gesprintet
sodass die Gruppe keinen Runspeed mehr hatte
weil er weg war und dann ist er allein gestorben
und sowas
das sind so Dinger die fucken mich übertrieben ab
und ich denke mir Leute
ihr spielt das Game seit über 20 Jahren
aber ihr seid nicht in der Lage einfach mal auf die Karte
zu gucken wo die Gruppe ist
das ist nicht mal Basics
das ist was was ein Level 1 Typ
lernt
der neu in dem Game ist
man muss immer gucken wo die anderen Gruppenmitglieder sind
aber nein der hat es nicht hingekriegt
und das hat mich so aufgeregt
oder zum Beispiel
wir sind in ein Boot gestiegen um woanders hinzufahren
im PvP Gebiet
er hat es wieder nicht gecheckt
war 30 Sekunden AFK
ist dann gestorben
an der Bootanlegestelle
und hat dann gemeint
Guys where are you
seit 30 Sekunden im Boot und schon weg
das hat mich übelst aufgeregt
so Leute hast du halt massig dort
wo ich mir immer denke
Mann Leute
ihr spielt das Game seit 20 Jahren
und ihr seid schlechter
als jemand der es 2 Wochen spielt
der sich ein bisschen Mühe gibt
das kann doch nicht sein
so das regt mich
das ist eines der Sachen
die mich tatsächlich
was extrem unwichtig ist
aber worüber ich mich sehr aufregen kann
ja ist es
die Leute sind so schlecht
es ist unglaublich
wie schlecht Leute in Games sein können
die sie seit 20 Jahren spielen
speichere sie
Google will C schrittweise ausmustern
sollen sie Rust verwenden
außerdem
hat Google nicht angefangen
irgend so einen komischen
C++
irgendein C++ Dialekt
oder irgendwie sowas zu entwickeln
wie hieß denn das
Carbon oder
Google
wie läuft denn das eigentlich so
interessiert keinen so wirklich
oder
ich mein hat viele viele Sterne
wie gesagt ich hab ja von Anfang an
ich das gesehen hab prophezeit
das ist vielleicht sowas für Google Leute
aber das wird keine weitreichende Verbreitung
finden
außerdem finde ich das übelst hässlich aus
da kann ich auch gleich Rust verwenden
wenn ich Kompatibilität zu C++
Libraries und Sachen brauch dann natürlich schwierig
ja das kann schon sein
möglich möglich
dann ist aber die erste Frage
warum spielt man ein Gruppenbasiertes
PvP MMO
und geht in Gruppen und spielt nicht Solo
und es ist für die eigene
Gaming Experience ja auch schlecht
weil man permanent tot ist und Scheiße spielt
und das dritte ist
so nach 20 Jahren sollte man auch
so einen gewissen Mindestanspruch daran haben
wenn man ein Spiel spielt
so die absoluten Basics
die Einsteiger am ersten Tag lernen zu können oder
ah ja GitHub Trends gute Frage
müssen wir gleich mal gucken
hat Max ein Video über sein Setup
ich spiele nicht
auf Linux
glaubst du nicht ernsthaft
dass ich mir das antue unter Linux zu spielen
ich spiele nicht unter Linux
ich spiele unter Windows und hab meine Linux Kiste
hier am Start wenn ich Linux Sachen
brauche
ich bin doch nicht lebensmüde
und mach hauptsächlich
Gaming unter Linux
Videobearbeitung
Thumbnails Streaming
und Gaming das mach ich mal schön unter Windows
und alles was Technik bezogen ist
mach ich schön unter Linux
ich benutze das was seine Stärken hat
ja dort wo es seine Stärken hat
und versuche nicht zwangsläufig
alles unter einem zu machen
also ich kann dir das auch nur empfehlen
wenn du möglichst wenig Probleme haben willst
was Gaming angeht
dann spiel einfach weiter unter Windows
nichts nichtsdestotrotz
funktioniert erstaunlich viel mittlerweile
recht gut unter Linux
so wenig Tabs ich hab nicht so wenig Tabs offen
hier hab ich noch ein paar offen
und hier hab ich das was du gesehen hast
ist nur Chrome
wir haben einen Tag alle zwei Wochen
haben wir Sprint Planung
Sprint Retrospektive
Sprint Review und alle mögliche
wie kann man 7TB hosten
kommt drauf an
wie schnell das angebunden sein muss
80% Meetings die Woche
ist halt komplett lächerlich immer
ist bei mir ja wie gesagt
ich hab ja ausgerechnet diese Woche hatte ich 75% Meetings
ist halt absolut lächerlich
weil dieses ganze in meeting gehocken
ist meistens meistens nicht alles
bei manchen ist es auch nicht so
meistens braucht man dort deine Expertise
überhaupt nicht du bist einfach nur dabei
weil du vielleicht zufälligerweise in der richtigen Gruppe
in der richtigen Abteilung im richtigen Projekt bist
aber um das was es da geht
ist vollkommen egal ob du jetzt guter Entwickler
schlechter Entwickler bist Durchblick bei der Architektur
hast sonst was du bist einfach nur dabei
oftmals muss man diesen Meetings ja nicht mal
großartig was zu beitragen und sagen
aber am Ende wenn du nicht
dabei gewesen bist und sagst hä wie
hab ich gar nicht mitgekriegt sagen sie dir
ja wärs beim Meeting gewesen hättest du es mitgekriegt
nö ich nicht
ich find's da ganz gut Bezahlung ist gut
ähm Homeoffice Regelung ist gut
äh Arbeit an sich
ist auch ok
es sind halt sehr viele Meetings
aber ich denk mir
wenn die Firma das will
und wenn die sich dann auch nicht beschweren am Ende
dass halt nix geschafft wird
soll es so sein
ich hab da prinzipiell keine Schmerzen da mit
6 Stunden am Tag zu meeten
oder 75% zu meeten
das ist easy
das ist easy verdientes Geld
auf den meisten Meetings musst du
kannst du nicht großartig was beitragen
weil es gar nicht um deine Sachen geht
aber vielleicht musst du ab und zu was mitkriegen
guckst du auf den zweiten Bildschirm Twitch
oder irgendwas
also ich mach ja meistens während ich meete
irgendwas anderes nebenbei
irgendwelche
Terraform Sachen anpassen
oder vielleicht wenn mich irgendein Entwickler
angeschrieben hat
kommt von seinem Entwicklungs-VM
nicht mehr auf die Entwicklungsumgebung drauf
da guck ich irgendwie
ob er es verkackt hat mit seinen
SSH Tunneln und sowas
das mach ich meistens
ich mach ja meistens sogar noch was sinnvolles neben den Meetings
das ist nämlich dann auch
so ein Ding wo die Planung
nicht mit der Realität übereinstimmt
weil guck mal
dir wird jeder Projektmanager oder sonst was sagen
mehr als 100% kann man nicht verplanen
das stimmt aber gar nicht
genau genommen
weil wie
ist es jetzt Chat
stellt euch mal vor ihr sitzt eine Stunde auf einem Meeting
dann habt ihr eine Stunde
für dieses Meeting quasi verplant
aber wenn ihr in dieser Stunde
während ihr eigentlich nur im Meeting sitzt
was arbeitet
dann habt ihr ja eigentlich 150%
gearbeitet
in dieser Stunde
ihr habt die offiziell geplante Meetingzeit
gehabt plus ihr habt noch was anderes
gearbeitet nebenbei
wie bildet man sowas
in der Planung ab
der Friseur ja den gibts noch
der hat sich auf Twitch umbenannt habe ich gesehen
der streamt aber nur so komische Mobile Weep Games
ich hab gerade nichts was ich mit dem
ESP32 in der Heimautomatisierung
umsetzen will
Moin Sarix
würdest du auch 75% mieten
wenn du 100% arbeiten würdest
vielleicht minimal weniger
weil zumindest
wenn ich mir meinen Kalender angucke
also montags
gar nicht so viele Meetings sind
das könnte aber natürlich sein
dass ich montags einfach
nicht so viele Meetings im Kalender stehen habe
weil ich montags nicht da bin
also die laden mich
montags halt auch gar nicht ein
was dann im Endeffekt heißt
wahrscheinlich hätte ich montags genauso viele Meetings
wenn ich regelmäßig da wäre
und dementsprechend
wahrscheinlich
auch mit Montag 75%
gemiete
man weiß das oftmals nicht
ja man weiß das oftmals nicht richtig
weil vielleicht kommt oftmals
also es kommt ja oftmals doch ab und zu was
wozu man was sagen will oder was nicht schlecht ist mitbekommen zu haben
ja
bei komplett unsinnigen
Sachen versuche ich das im Vorfeld
eigentlich schon mich da abzumelden
Drasilisk
danke für den Sub
ja aber was machst du denn
wenn in der Agenda schon Themen draufstehen
die dich theoretisch betreffen könnten
aber dann halt am
das kommt dann sagen wir mal am Ende eine Viertelstunde
und in Wirklichkeit selbst wenn es dran kommt
heißt dann nicht mal ob das sich jetzt konkret
interessiert
stell dir mal vor da ist irgendein Agenda Punkt
Cloud Infrastruktur drauf
das ist das letzte Stunde Meeting
das ist das letzte Thema
wird die letzten 15 Minuten angesprochen
und im Endeffekt stellt sich dann
stellt sich dann raus okay
du sagst da einen Satz zu
und dann bist du wieder geistig afk
kannst du halt auch nicht im Vorfeld absagen
das ist nicht so einfach
ich mach das ich setz mich da eine Stunde rein
ich hab da echt keine Schmerzen
wenn die Firma das will
die bezahlen mich im Endeffekt für 75% Mieten soll mir recht sein
warte mal herrlich dankeschön für den Sub
so
wir gucken jetzt mal
was denn unsere Shithub Trends so machen
ja
Shithub Trends
this week
tja ich würde auch mal ganz gern
irgendwas sinnvolles machen
zwei drei Tage am Stück
aber das kannst du vergessen
deswegen krieg ich auch nichts geschafft
aber ich mecker da jedes mal bei meinem Chef drüber
und im Endeffekt
hat sich bei mir bisher noch keiner beschwert
dass Sachen nicht fertig werden
und wenn halt Sachen nicht fertig werden
dann sag ich halt ja gut
guck hier mein Kalender 75% Meetings wann
ach guck mal
ein Nintendo Switch Emulator Trended
auf Github
woran könnte das nur liegen?
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob sich Nintendo
einen Gefallen damit getan hat
ich glaube viel mehr Leute sind jetzt überhaupt
dadurch erst auf die
auf den Trichter gekommen
dass es Switch Emulatoren gibt
die das im Vorfeld gar nicht wussten
doch klar
ich weiß wie du es meinst
ja aber es ist nicht verboten
einen Emulator zu benutzen
ich hab natürlich alle meine ROMs
selbst gerippt
ist doch klar
ja ist so
also
Screenshot to Code
Drop in a Screenshot and convert it to Screenshot
ah das ist AI
das habe ich schon mal gesehen
genau du pastest ein Screenshot
und das analysiert
dein Screenshot mit AI
und baut dir das dann nach in HTML
und CSS
das ist eigentlich eine coole Idee
richtig coole Idee
ne ist es nicht
sobald du Kopierschutz umgehst
ist es immer problematisch
aber das muss ja glücklicherweise
das Projekt
das den Emulator programmiert nicht interessieren
das muss dich interessieren
so
äh
juckt nicht
Kickstart NeoWim
Leute ich wollte ja mal einen NeoWim Stream machen
wo wir das einrichten
zumal ich ja selbst davon relativ wenig Ahnung hab
ich hab früher
super krass aufgebohrten Wim verwendet
noch bevor es NeoWim gab
bin ich schon seit einer ganzen Weile wieder weg von
also ich verwende Wim zwar immer noch
mehrfach
also längere Zeit am Tag
täglich
aber halt nur Basic
ja wenn ich irgendwie Kommandozeilen mäßig was
gucken, nachgucken muss, schnell editieren muss
dann Wim
ansonsten für Frontend Sachen und Microcontroller
Visual Studio Code
und für die anderen Sachen halt Jetbrain IDE
ich mein muss sich lohnen dass ich mir das
Jetbrain All Desktop Package gekauft hab
mittlerweile bin ich glaub ich sogar schon
im dritten Jahr oder über dem dritten Jahr raus
das heißt ich krieg's sogar ein bisschen günstiger
aber ich find
des Jetbrains Zeug wenn man
auch nur Semi damit sein Geld verdient
lohnt sich schon
es ist nicht so teuer es kost glaub ich
im ersten Jahr irgendwie 300 Dollar im Jahr
das find ich
gerechtfertigt für dieses All Desktop Pack
frisst halt ramm wie sonst was der Kram
das stimmt
das ist halt bloated
Java Zeug
aber es funktioniert gut
und man hat ja heutzutage glücklicherweise
genug RAM
ok
Pingora
ne
oder Pingora
Cloudflare
Library for building fast reliable
and evolvable network services
ok
eine Rust Library von Cloudflare
Blazingly fast
ist die denn Blazing
ne ist sie nicht
Blazingly fast sein weil das ist in Rust
gerittet
geritten
written in Rust
ok ich wüsste nicht wann ich die verwenden soll
ok keine Ahnung
ich weiß nicht was es ist
das haben wir doch schon gesehen
es kommt jetzt ein
what the fuck
ok
Windows in a Docker Container
dokuhr
Windows
Moment ist es Docker in Windows
oder Windows in Docker
Windows in a Docker
das ist 100% Bait Leute
Windows kann nicht in einem Docker Container
laufen
das ist genau das
Splixer das ist das was ich auch vermutet habe
das ist wahrscheinlich
schlicht ergreifend ein Docker Image
wo du
KVM Pass Through
machen musst
von deinem Host
und dann ist es halt
ein fertiges Image
von Windows was der in der VM startet
also wahrscheinlich relativ
simpel aber
bestimmt praktisch
warum sollte man Windows in einem Container haben wollen
es ist ja nicht Windows in einem Container
es ist ja wahrscheinlich nur ein KVM
Start Script
im Container
insofern
stelle ich es mir ganz praktisch vor
wenn du mal schnell ein cleanes Windows brauchst
ist es doch eigentlich ganz nice
alternativ man kann sich auch einfach
eine Windows VM machen mit einem Snapshot
wenn man das öfters macht
ach guck mal hier
du kannst dich sogar per Browser direkt drauf einloggen
ist doch eigentlich ganz cool
das ist ja wie ich gesagt habe
du musst KVM vom Host durch
pass throughen
weil
es kann kein Windows in einem Container sein
weil Windows nicht unter Linux läuft
und Container
keine VMs sind
Container sind ganz normale
Linux Prozesse
und dementsprechend
kann Windows nicht unter Linux laufen
wäre es möglich
Windows als Container laufen zu lassen
dann könntest du
Windows auch generell unter Linux laufen lassen
was keinen Sinn ergibt
also
weil Windows kein Binary ist
was du einfach ausführst
aber das war klar
dass es eben ein KVM mit pass through ist
dementsprechend ist ja
Docker unter Windows auch gelogen
das sind
auch VMs
wenn Windows irgendwann mal
den Linux Kernel bekommt geht das vielleicht
ne
selbst dann geht das nicht
weil das ja gerade eines der
hauptsächlichen Unterschiede ist
zwischen Containern und VMs
Container sind ein weiterer Prozess
der im gleichen Host Kernel
läuft VMs ist voll virtualisiert
mit eigenem Kernel
du kannst auch Linux nicht unter Linux
in einem Container ausführen
was du machen kannst ist
Prozess starten in einem Container
der seine eigenen
Abhängigkeiten mitbringt
aber das ist kein eigenes Linux was da drin läuft
das ist im Prinzip nur die eigenen
Abhängigkeiten die das jeweilige Binary
braucht weil du kannst natürlich noch
deutlich mehr da drin ausliefern
kannst auch nur Bash ausliefern und sonst was
aber es ist streng genommen kein Linux
was in diesem Container läuft
es ist ein Linux Image mit den Binary
und den Abhängigkeiten aber es bleibt immer
der gleiche Host Kernel
das ist was Container ausmacht
und das ist was Container auch so
leichtgewichtig und schnell macht
beziehungsweise schnell
kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten
Performance Unterschied zwischen Container und VM
ist CPU technisch jetzt nicht
so großartig
ich würde sagen außer mit Benchmarks
so gar nicht wirklich
feststellbar
der riesen Unterschied zwischen Containern und VMs
was die Ressourcenauslastung angeht
ist der Speicherverbrauch
sowohl Diskspeicher
also SSDs
Plattenspeicher als vor allem auch RAM Usage
und RAM Auslastung
weil wenn du einen Container startest
einen Prozess startest
dann braucht das in einem Container
nicht bedeutend mehr
als wenn du den Prozess direkt
unter deinem Host System startest
weil es ist ja im Prinzip ein weiterer Prozess
unter deinem Host System
und in einer VM musst du ein komplett eigenes
Betriebssystem starten das heißt
du brauchst für den Prozess vielleicht
du hast bei einem Container
vielleicht ein paar
MB Overhead
wenn überhaupt
und bei einer VM
wahrscheinlich
ein paar 100 MB Overhead
je nachdem es gibt natürlich Versuche
so mit Micro-VMs und sowas
das ist ja eines der hauptsächlichen Unterschiede
dazwischen
ich mache übrigens Chatgear ihr müsst demnächst Beta testen
ich habe auf der Arbeit gesagt
ich mache mal eine Einführung zu Linux Container
...
und da wollte ich mir wirklich mal
die Funktionsweise ein bisschen genauer angucken
so wie das ganze, wo das ganze herkommt
und so die Vorgänger
so von
ChangeRoute zu falls noch jemand
OpenVZ kennt
...
dann starten wir auch mal
einen
Prozess
ohne Docker
aber ähnlich zu dem was Docker macht
so und
ich muss mir da noch ein bisschen was aus den Fingern saugen
aber ihr müsst ein Beta Tester sein
ich zeige euch das dann
im Stream
es geht ungefähr
ich habe das ungefähr so eine Stunde geplant
also Inhalt wird sein
laggt es gerade auch
ne hör mal auf Vodafone please
ne laggt nichts
keine
no lag
ne es laggt überhaupt nicht
also bei euch vielleicht aber
bei mir laggt nichts
vielleicht laggt Twitch auch
das kann sein aber
es liegt nicht an mir
also
Ziel wird sein
dass wir uns einmal so ein bisschen historisch angucken
wie das mit Containern ist
und so ein bisschen Docker Hello World machen
im Endeffekt
man muss ja auch sagen, dass Docker ungleich
Linux Container ist
Docker ist im Prinzip nur ein Kommandozeilen Tool
das man
easy Container verwalten kann
ne nicht wirklich ein Kurs so eine Stunde
Stunde Übersicht
und da gucken wir uns vielleicht am Ende nochmal kurz an
wie man möglichst schön Multistage Container Image baut
das es nicht 800 MB am Ende groß ist
die Wubblos Masterclass
genau
gibt es da ein Zertifikat am Ende
ja kannst du
äh
bilde ich mir zumindest ein, dass ich das schon gemacht habe
relativ safe geht das
ich glaube das habe ich mit dem FIA Champ schon gemacht
bevor da Public war
ja und da müsste
ich muss mir da aber noch was fertig aus den Fingern saugen
das geht so ungefähr eine Stunde
das wird dann ein bisschen
nicht wirklich
Powerpoint weil
ich mag
kein Powerpoint
das wird aber so ein bisschen
sagen wir mal Powerpoint ähnlich
und dann Terminal was ausprobieren
ich muss mir das überlegen
wenn ich mir was aus den Fingern gesaugt habe
dann
dürft ihr Beta testen im Stream
ob man das versteht was ich da erzähle
ja Container in irgendeiner Art
und Weise gibt es schon sehr lang
und Linux ist auch nicht das einzige
also ist auch nicht die ersten
die angefangen haben
wobei Linux Container halt abgehoben sind
so richtig mit Linux
gerade als Docker dann aufgekommen ist
ich meine viele andere Betriebssysteme
haben sowas auch
du hast BSD Jails
du hast Solaris Container
und solche Dinger sowas gibt es
ja schon ewig
und
letztendlich
ob man jetzt
Portman verwendet Docker verwendet
Kubernetes verwendet
oder irgendwas anderes zum Container starten
unter der Haube
ist das
alles das gleiche
was sich unterscheidet
ist die Handhabung der jeweiligen
Tools ja auch das
Management herum herum was Netzwerk angeht
was Images angeht und sowas
aber das eigentliche starten
oder quasi
Prozess im Container ausführen
das ist bei allem das gleiche
das basiert alles auf Namespaces
und Cgroups
und das kann man auch von Hand machen
mit Unshare zum Beispiel
das Kommandozeilen Tool
um Namespace Funktionalität
verwenden zu können
das kann man auch von Hand machen
aber natürlich nicht so schön
wie mit irgendeinem ordentlichen Container Tool
aber unter der Haube
ist das alles das gleiche
echt
ich hab die
schonmal gemacht
aber die hat mir nicht gefallen
weil die zu spontan war
so ich wollt mir angucken was auf Shithub trendet
also Windows hatten wir
Webcheck
Aha Starcoder
Home of Starcoder 2
alles klar jetzt weiß man Bescheid
ah
ahja AI
AI
guck mal ein weiterer Emulator trendet
wie gesagt ich glaube Nintendo hat sich damit
kein gefallen getan
viele Leute sind jetzt erstmal darauf aufmerksam geworden
dass es Emulatoren gibt die die übelsten
Kacknoobs waren und das gar nicht wussten
AI
Redis Client
schön für ihn
China Chinesen Java
Kram
Android Stealth
AI
Unity Stealth
es ist selten dass C-Libraries trenden
ok
bei diesen ganzen Projektlogos
hab ich immer den Eindruck
dass mittlerweile alles AI generated
ach das ist eine
C-Standard Library Implementierung
die überall läuft
aha
das klingt aber eigentlich ganz cool
aber C ist unsafe
ja du hast recht
Krustentiere approven das nicht
aber es ist echt cool
das ist blazingly fast
obwohl es nicht written in rust ist
das hab ich auch mal ne weile bei mir verwendet
um meine Hardware zu tracken
aber ich war dann zu faul für das zu verwenden
gar keinen Screenshot von
das ist eigentlich ganz nice
aber das ist Overkill für mich gewesen
Open Dit
was?
Dit
ich weiß nicht was Dit ist aber wahrscheinlich AI
im Zweifelsfall wenn ich es
ist es AI
im Dotnet Umfeld
Switch Emulator
Power Toys China Chinesen Dotnet Guide
aha was lernen die da so
die haben schon mal das Emoji Game
durchgespielt
das finde ich schon mal sehr sehr nice
ok lasst uns das mal kurz translaten
follow like share
exzellent
die haben das Emoji Game aber mal richtig durchgespielt
hier
das ist so eine awesome Collection für Dotnet
in was ist denn das für ne Sprache
keine Ahnung ist das Chinesisch ist das Japanisch
ist das man weiß es nicht
oder steht das da oben dabei
Chinesisch ja Chinesisch
AI
das gibt es noch
Chinesenkram
Accept Bitcoin Payments
ok Leute
ich wollte schon immer Bitcoins
Bitcoin Payments Accepten
Maui
jedes mal wenn ich sehe frage ich mich wann der Blogpost
von Microsoft kommt wann es eingestellt wird
was ist das denn?
Remote Admin Tool für Windows
so sieht es doch aus
ok
nice jetzt sind wir auf dem aktuellen Stand
was Shithub angeht
Nachricht aus der Zukunft
korrekt
Nudeln mit Tomatensoße und Hackfleisch
gibt es heute
Leute
stellt euch vor
ich habe letztens
ich spiele immer noch Dark
auf dem Freeshard
dort spielt auch eine
semibekannte italienische
Foodbloggerin
und ich habe die letztens gefragt
wie sie Schnitzel findet
und die meinte I don't like it
wie kann man Schnitzel nicht mögen
ich meine was sie auf ihrem Blog postet
ist richtig nice
aber so ein Schnitzel ist trotzdem nice
richtig lost oder
und sie meinte sie findet
oh was
Kotletto oder sowas
Kotoletta
findet sie besser als Schnitzel
da habe ich mir ein Bild angeguckt
und habe mir gedacht
das sieht halt einfach aus wie ein Schnitzel
ich weiß nicht was der Unterschied ist
dazwischen
das sieht halt wirklich schon aus
wie ein Schnitzel halt
wie ein Schnitzel
Moment das ist kein Schnitzel
da ist
das ne
ne Moment
das ist kein Schnitzel
das ist das Bein oder so
ja kann sein verstehe ich nicht
paniertes Rippchen oder sowas
ja
diese Woche wäre Lachs dran
ne das stimmt nicht Lachs war letzte Woche dran
so
Life of a Zoomer Gen 7
warum Youtube
warum denkt Youtube dass ich mir das angucken
ich habe von diesem Channel
bisher noch nichts gehört
aber Life of a Zoomer Gen Z
Gen Z Meme
taugen die Videos was
doch angeklickt
da ist er wieder
der Anzeige Hauptmeister
ok was haben wir denn sonst
was ist das
Apple Drops Ben Hammer on Epic Games
over Mean Tweet
btw heißt das eigentlich noch Tweet
wie nennt man das jetzt eigentlich
seitdem es X ist
Over Mean X
X Message
ist schon wieder outdated
das neue lohnt sich das Video
ist echt gut
das da
Job auf Windrad
im Meer bringt alles ans Limit
oh das
stelle ich mir sehr
also nicht nur anstrengend vor
sondern
so von da oben runter gucken
ich war mal als ich klein war
im Schwimmbad
im
wie hieß das Ding in Frankfurt
gibts nicht mehr
ähm
wie hieß dieses Schwimmbad
in Frankfurt
Schwimmbad Wellen
nicht Wellness
Rebstock
das Rebstockbad genau
Rebstock was macht eigentlich das Rebstockbad
das gibts nicht mehr
ich dachte das soll umgebaut werden
aber sie kriegen es irgendwie nicht
nicht gebacken
das wird neu gebaut irgendwie seit 50 Jahren
oder so
bis zum Jahr 2025 soll das am gleichen
für 90 Millionen Euro
das ist nächstes Jahr bis nächstes Jahr
ist das garantiert nicht fertig im Leben nicht
zumindest das Rebstockbad das war früher mega nice
und zwar man sieht es hier vielleicht auch
die
man sieht nen übelst dicken Dude im Wasser stehen
schon mal nice
ja hier hinten
hier hinten sieht mans und zwar hier hinten hatten die
10 Meter Brett
und
ich weiß noch als ich klein war
das ist so ein extra tiefes
extra tiefes Becken hier
ging irgendwie 3 Meter 7 oder so runter
10 Meter Brett
als ich klein war habe ich mal übelst auf dicke Hose gemacht
da war ich mit meinem Vater im
Gredolange für den Zap
das haben wir dafür
hä hat der nicht ein 10 Meter Brett auch
ne das
oder ist da nebenan noch was
wie auch immer
2er 3er 5er
ne oder
war das vielleicht in einem anderen Schwimmbad
zumindest
egal
oder ist da oben noch was
dann war es woanders
aber zumindest hier war ich mit meinem Vater und als ich klein war
habe ich da übelst auf dicke Hose gemacht
habe es easy gar kein Problem hier ich hüpfe da runter
und sonst was
dann bin ich zum ersten mal
dann bin ich zum ersten mal auf so ein Sprungbrett
weil von unten sieht das überhaupt nicht hoch aus
ja
bin ich zum ersten mal auf das
auf das Ding hochgeklettert
und du musst hier hochklettern dann da hochklettern
und als ich auf dem war habe ich schon runter
geguckt und habe mir gedacht oh fuck
das ist ja viel höher als ich gedacht habe
und dann bin ich da hoch
geklettert und habe runter geguckt
und habe mir gedacht oh scheiße
alter ist das tief
und da ist mir zum ersten mal aufgefallen
dass dir das viel höher vorkommt
wenn du von oben ins Wasser runter guckst
weil du guckst ja von hier ins Wasser runter und siehst ja
du fühlst die Höhe von hier plus nochmal
die Höhe ins Wasser
alter ich hätte mir fast in die Hose geschissen
aber ich bin runter gehüpft
aber wie alter
wirklich von vorne dann so einen ganz kleinen Satz
und schnell wieder raus
da hatte ich
da hatte ich echt Schiss als ich da erstmal drauf bin
ja
also aber das Schwimmbad war richtig nice
hier gab es Wellen drinnen
also keine Ahnung
warum es das nicht mehr gibt
ich hoffe ich hoffe
ich hoffe das gibt
guck mal was es hier News gibt
ne
nix
ach jetzt sind wir bis 2027
Leute
es ist so schlimm
warum kriegen wir in Deutschland nie Projekte
auch nur ansatzweise
das ist bis 2027
unfertig
wir hätten mal ansatzweise irgendwie fertig
so kacke alter
die Chinesen hätten schon 3 Rebstockbäder
gebaut
gut dann wären vielleicht im Fundament 5 Arbeiter
oder so zufällig mit eingegossen
oder was aber es wäre zumindest
fertig gebaut
wie lange es halten würde wäre was anderes
schlimm
ok wo ist der
ok
Job auf Windrad
im Meer bringt alle ans Limit
ok das gucken wir uns jetzt an
Limitge
die ursprüngliche Planung heißt bis 2025
soll es fertig sein
wenn es bis 2025 fertig sein soll
sollte man den Auftrag halt vielleicht nicht
ja
bis Mitte 2024 starten wir
machen
wir sind gerade in einer Störung
also so soll es auch gehen
jetzt haben wir ein Notis Connect
WTF
da geht einfach
da geht einfach die Brücke weg
ok das gucken wir uns an
wir sind gerade in einer Störung also so soll es auch gehen
jetzt haben wir ein Notis Connect
das Wetter kann sehr schnell umschlagen
die letzten Tage waren kritisch
nein wir brechen die Aktion ab
Ende
weil es einfach zu gefährlich wird
das Offshore Geld ist gut
da kann man sich nicht drüber beschweren
dass der Fahrstuhl kaputt ist in der Windturbine
und Abflug
das kommt nicht so häufig vor
oh shit
Hallo zusammen
ich bin der Johann und ich arbeite als Techniker
auf der Nordsee in der Offshore Windenergie
heute nehmen wir euch mit
und zeigen euch unsere Welt
Gerhard ja das kann schon sein
da kenne ich mich nicht mit aus
aber hier hast du halt das Problem
wenn die seltene Froschart auf dem
Gelände nistet
dann musst du schon mal 2 Jahre verschieben
bis sie umgesiedelt sind
so und jetzt wird geschleppt
wir haben Wetterprognosen
die eigentlich nicht besonders gut sind
es wird am Anfang wahrscheinlich erstmal
die Musik im Hintergrund Alter!
ich mache das seit 5 Jahren
ich kenne diese Situation
aber Seekrankheit ist nicht unbedingt vorhersehbar
Moin zusammen
Kotzke
jetzt fahren wir gerade aus Norddeich raus
Alter die übelste Wighängermusik
Mann
Maschine gar nichts mehr
Tja
Hallo Olaf
So Team Chaos meldet sich
Der Kapitän versucht
an der Wind of Change anzudocken
und zu pushen
aber ob das jetzt geht wissen wir noch nicht
Der eine ist schon halb seekrank
Oah Kotzke
Ich würde sagen seekrank
Kamerafrau und
Redakteurin Moderatorin
ist wohl auf
und mir gehts super
Bis später Ciao
Wir sind jetzt auf dem großen
Operation Vessel
das ist also so ein bisschen das Mutterschiff
was hier rumdümpelt
das ist dann unser Crewbereich
in dem wir unsere Ruhe finden können
die eigene Kabine
Service Operation Vessel
ich wette mit dir das wird in Deutschland abgekürzt
das nennen sie wahrscheinlich
dann nur noch SOV oder sowas
man hat schon ein bisschen Platz
jeder hat und das finde ich eigentlich sehr wichtig
seinen eigenen Dusch- und Toilettenraum
schon ein sehr schöner Moment
wenn ich morgens aufwache und den Sonnenaufgang
sehe
ich mach das auch gerne auch
Aber nice oder?
Ist ne coole Kabine ist das größer als ich mir das vorgestellt hätte
Aber in den letzten Tagen wäre das keine gute Idee gewesen
Dann wäre hier wahrscheinlich das Wasser reingelaufen
So man hört es schon
pfeifen
Windke
Ich arbeite zwei Wochen am Stück
von Montags bis Sonntags
und dann wieder von vorne
und hab dann entsprechend als Ausgleich
danach die zwei Wochen frei
Die Zeit kann ja doch sehr lang werden auf dem Schiff
Deswegen haben wir noch einen Sportbereich
Man muss jetzt nicht der Kletterer sein
um in der Windturbine klar zu kommen
Es ist mehr das Leiternklettern
wenn mal wirklich der Fahrstuhl kaputt ist
aber das kommt nicht so häufig vor
Die große Kantine
unsere kleine Beachbar
dass wir ein bisschen rausschauen können
Hier haben wir noch ein Helikopterdeck
Und so schaut dann die Windhoffchain von der anderen Seite aus
Das ist so hier erstmal unsere Welt
Großes Teil
Der Chat meint
Flohsan meint
hätte richtig Bock auf den Job
Ich nicht
Call of Duty Map
Das operative Geschäft findet natürlich nur dann statt
wenn vorher eine vernünftige Planung stattgefunden hat
und dort sitzen dann verschiedene Positionen
die sich darum kümmern
dass das Tagesgeschäft läuft
welche Turbinen laufen, welche stehen
Wenn wir dann wieder navigieren wollen
haben wir entsprechende Schaubilder von den Windparks
die aufgebaut sind
wie die Netze miteinander verbunden sind
Wenn es da Probleme gibt
springst du auch nicht einfach mal runter
mit 140 Meter bist du Matsch
Das ist einer von den kritischen Fehlern
dann wird kein Strom produziert
deswegen haben wir auch versucht
möglichst schnell zu reagieren
Wir sehen, dass hier schon Gewitter reinkommt
Also hier in den Niederlanden sind gerade Blitzeinschläge
Also es zieht gerade nach oben
Schauen wir mal wie es da aussieht
Wir sehen, dass die Welle relativ weit oben ist
Also können wir nicht mit unseren CTVs operieren
ausschließlich mit der Gangway
Ob da auf dem Schiff
auch wohl ein Programmierer nicht
aber ITler werden die da garantiert auch
Technik, Elektro, IT, Hybridleute
hast du garantiert auch auf dem Schiff
weil da immer mal was sein kann
Was?
Okay
Schauen wir mal
ob wir tatsächlich euch morgen versetzen können
Wir werden uns auf einen vollen Arbeitstag vorbereiten
Wir müssen uns quasi dem fügen
was wir dann morgen erleben
durch das Wetter
Alter
Haben wir nicht irgendwo ein Wikinger Emoji?
Doch hier
Sekunde
Morgen
Oh oh
...
Wir haben euch gefragt耶
ablassen. Wenn jetzt quasi das Gepäckstück runtergelassen wird und das Schiff bewegt sich
in der Zeit, dann müssen wir eben aufpassen, dass das nicht kollidiert, dass ich da vorsichtig bin
beim Aushaken, dass ich mich nicht verletze. Incoming. Okay.
Ah, schon ein bisschen windig, ja? So, wir haben das Cargo. Jetzt haben wir drei neue Module bekommen.
Es musste jetzt eben schnell gehen, deswegen hat sich der Helikopter-Einsatz heute gelohnt. Sonst hätten wir
wahrscheinlich zwei, drei Tage warten müssen und dann sind die Kosten von dem Helikopterflug
natürlich wesentlich geringer als die Ausfallkosten von der Turbine. Ja, dann gehen wir erstmal essen.
Hallo. Alkohol, Drogen, alles, was in irgendeiner Weise die Sinne betäubt, ist strengstens verboten.
Dürfen wir uns bei euch dazusetzen? Wir machen jetzt das letzte Wetter-Update von der Brücke und dann
fangen wir an.
Dann packen wir jetzt. Wir haben Troubleshooter-Kits und da haben wir schon mal eine ganze Menge an Werkzeug drin,
um so die meisten Dinge dann auch zu reparieren. Pumpensatz. Ich wüsste ja gar nicht, wo ich anfangen müsste damit.
Da haben wir genug Wasser da drin. Deswegen sind es ja auch die Pros. Wenn wir uns an dem Turm annähern, dann können wir schon starten.
Es gibt verschiedene Level vom Techniker. Je höher das Level, desto höher auch die Bezahlung.
Okay, was haben wir? Basisstufe, klassischer Team-Lead?
Moment. Team-Lead ist nur Stufe 2. Offshore-Troubleshooter, Senior-Techniker.
Aber nicht jeder will jedes Level erreichen. Ich habe jetzt relativ neu den Level 4, also den Senior-Technischen.
Okay, das hat jetzt schon mal nicht geklappt.
Geht ja gut los.
Das habe ich noch nie so gehabt.
Das macht Mut.
Ist ja direkt wieder disconnected.
Alter, die Musik. Das wäre nichts für mich, sage ich euch ganz ehrlich.
Wir sind gerade in einer Störung. Jetzt haben wir einen Not-Disconnect. Und das ist nicht geil.
Schauen wir mal schnell, dass wir uns hier...
Wind of Change, VK1 Radio-Check.
Das, was jetzt passiert ist, ist eben so ein Not-Disconnect.
War zu sehr gewackelt, wahrscheinlich, weil es zu sehr gewackelt hat.
Nein, die werden es jetzt natürlich nochmal versuchen. Aber dadurch, dass wir sehr kritisches Wetter haben,
haben wir direkt Situationen, die wir eigentlich nicht sagen.
Und die wir eigentlich nicht unbedingt haben möchten.
Und das habe ich so in der Realität bisher noch nie gesehen.
Lass mich mal ganz kurz telefonieren.
Man muss bloß jetzt rüberspringen, wenn das mit der Brücke nicht funktioniert.
Ich muss mich mal mit dem anderen Teil des Teams abstimmen.
Aber das sind Situationen, in denen wir dann nicht mehr arbeiten möchten.
Weil es einfach zu gefährlich wird.
Ja, sollen wir Abbruch, oder?
Ja.
Wir sind jetzt zwei- oder dreimal abgerissen.
Nein, wir brechen die Abbruch.
Wir brechen die Reaktion ab. Ende.
Wind of Change von Mike01.
Hello guys, could you please tell us what your plan is now?
We need to check the alarm on.
That's all copied. Thank you for the update.
Sieht leider nicht gut aus.
Auf der Windturbine ist es arschkalt im Winter.
Es ist grün, heiß im Sommer.
Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, sich zu waschen.
Es gibt keine Toilette.
Es gibt eben nichts außer die Maschine.
Wir müssen abwarten, bis dann herausgefunden wird.
Wenn du da dünnsch ist, hast du es echt problematisch.
Ja, wir müssen abwarten, bis dann herausgefunden wird.
Wir müssen abwarten, bis dann herausgefunden wird.
Was eigentlich passiert ist.
Solange werden die quasi aus dem Sicherheitsbereich unserer Turbine rausfahren.
Deswegen entfernt sich gerade auch das Schiff.
Am Pinkel kann man da wahrscheinlich noch.
Wenn der Wind gut ist.
Haben die jetzt tatsächlich da irgendwie...
Ich meine, das war eben noch nicht mal Dämmerung.
Und jetzt ist es dunkel.
Und da steht immer noch da drauf.
Alter, ist das kacke.
Wir sind jetzt auf der Operation.
Das ist kein Problem.
Das ist alles gekopft. Danke.
Herzlich willkommen. Schön, jetzt seid ihr mit uns gefangen.
Dann können wir uns jetzt tatsächlich mal um die eigentliche Arbeit kümmern.
Also wir sind hier auf einer Offshore-Windturbine, das heißt für uns alle, das sind besondere Konditionen.
Hinter den Schaltschränken befinden sich Spannungen, die gefährlich sind, die uns töten würden, wenn wir sie berühren.
Wir haben bewegte mechanische Teile, absturzgefährdete Stellen.
So, dann haben wir das hier soweit fertig.
Kletter-Champ.
Bis später.
Also wir können froh sein, dass wir einen Fahrstuhl haben, der funktioniert.
Und dann sparen wir uns die Leiter.
Und jetzt geht er kaputt.
Das wären sonst um die 90 Meter hier im Turm.
Was blitzt denn der Fahrstuhl so?
Ne, das ist einfach ein Licht, so nach dem Motto, es fährt, oder?
Der Gurt ist eigentlich so.
Krass.
Wir müssen auf die nächste Ebene, wir müssen uns in der Turbine einbringen.
Da geht's ordentlich.
Da geht's ordentlich rauf, 100, was haben die gesagt, 145 Meter?
Aktuell sind wir noch ferngesteuert und das müssen wir ändern, damit Julian oben auch kraten kann.
Und wenn man es so sehen kann, sollte mir jetzt irgendwas passieren, hänge ich quasi hier drinnen und wäre halt geschützt.
Jetzt gibt es in der Windturbine den großen Schalter, damit wir die Anlage quasi überwinden.
Aber man muss mal sagen, sehr clean da drinnen, ja?
Jetzt ist sie uns.
Also wir brauchen hier irgendwie eine Art und Weise, wie wir mit der Anlage sprechen.
Und in dem Fall ist das dann hier unser Oldschool-Controller und dann ist der Kran oben aktiv.
Das ist dann nur unsere redundante Sicherung, weil die der Fahrstuhl abstürzen.
Wer soll denn da Dreck produzieren? Das frage ich mich bei mir daheim auch immer.
So.
Aber es geht trotzdem.
Und Abflug.
Das ist die Ebene, wo die Survival Barrels stehen, also da siehst du die Tonnen.
Falls alle gestorben sind und du bist der Einzige, der hier drauf ist.
Und du weißt nicht, was du machen sollst.
Da sind Schlafsäcke drinne und Wasser und Kekse.
Das ist aber nicht gut.
Wir hängen quasi an einem Seil, wo dann die Seilwinde uns hochzieht.
Und dazu haben wir nochmal ein Sicherungsseil, wenn wir fallen.
Jetzt ist genau das passiert, was irgendwie nicht sein sollte.
Ich sag doch, hier geht alles schief.
Monkeis.
Warte mal.
Alter Schöne.
Ja, ist nicht schlimm, aber wir sind halt...
Das war's.
Wir müssen klettern, also so können wir den Lift nicht benutzen.
Ich sag dir, heute geht alles schief.
Wir fahren unsere Plattform runter und schauen uns den Lift an.
Kletter-Champ.
Das habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Der Fahrstuhl ist gecrashed.
Wir sind in der Mitte der Ebene.
Ah, die ist gebrochen, das ist der Grund.
Ne, der Lift ist am Arsch, wir können nicht mehr.
Da müssen wir klettern.
Was ist los?
Du wirst mir das nicht glauben.
Du wirst mir das einfach nicht glauben.
Was?
Ich bin im falschen Steckenbetrieb.
Nein!
Ja, das ist recht.
Na gut, Portugal macht keinen Donnerwitz auf Abstand.
Also, Leute.
90 Meter Treppe hoch ist schon echt nicht ohne.
Aber 90 Meter Leiter?
Kletter-Champ.
Der Kameramann muss diesmal wirklich was schaffen für sein Geld.
Hey.
Also das ganze Drumherum, was wir bisher gesehen haben, ist alles schön und gut, aber...
Unser eigentlicher Beruf ist ja dann letztendlich doch im elektrischen Bereich oder auch im mechanischen.
Wir haben ja den Fehler an der Windturbine und da müssen wir jetzt das defekte Teil austauschen.
Wie ist denn der andere da jetzt hochgekommen?
Der ist von ganz unten geklettert, oder wie?
Fehler an der Windturbine und da müssen wir jetzt das defekte Teil austauschen.
Warte, warte, warte.
Irgendwo?
Ne.
Ich halte den rein und du kannst schrauben.
Perfekt.
Der hält.
Wir hoffen, dass das jetzt quasi auf Anhieb gut läuft.
Ich kann zum Beispiel mit dem Gehör feststellen, ist ein Lager defekt, macht das Geräusche, vibriert vielleicht ein Bauelement, also habe ich jetzt einen Getriebeschaden.
Der ist nicht zuerst gefahren.
Der stand doch eben nach unten, hat gesagt, die sind stecken geblieben, hat nach oben geguckt.
Jetzt haben wir gehört, die Bremsen lösen sich und dann müssten wir gleich eigentlich schon in Bewegung gehen.
Ne.
Nicht gut.
So, da hat was noch nicht funktioniert.
Kein Grund zur Panik.
Was macht man, wenn was nicht funktioniert?
Jeder kennt es von seinem Computer.
Reboot.
Erstmal ein Reset.
Testet durch.
Klar.
Was bei meinem Kühlschrank funktioniert, muss bei der Windturbine auch funktionieren.
Ah, wer hätte das gedacht.
Dann hat sich tatsächlich mal der Computer aufgehangen.
Dann machen wir gleich einmal einen vollständigen Testlauf.
Testläufe sind dann eine kritische Phase, deswegen auch wichtig, dass man da immer mit vollem Bewusstsein dabei ist.
Müssen mal gucken, dass alles, was hier rumfliegen kann und so, mal ein bisschen verstaut ist.
Und es wird laut.
Und jetzt würden wir die Anlage tatsächlich aufstarten.
Das heißt, wir drehen uns jetzt immer wieder rein.
Ausstarten.
Genau.
Und jetzt fangen wir an, Strom zu produzieren.
Und jetzt nimmt die erst richtig Fahrt auf.
Da braucht man Gehörschutzgel.
Ich hoffe, das läuft nicht mit Windows 3.11, wie bei der Bahn.
Also das ist ein Moment, den kann man auf sich wirken lassen.
Da halte ich ihn auch ganz gerne mal inne.
Was man da im Hintergrund sieht, sind das alles andere, alles auch Windräder?
Ich schaue mir das nochmal an, weil das ist schon ein bisschen unwirklich, wenn man hier rausschaut.
Was?
Dann haben wir das Schiff, das uns heute dann hoffentlich wieder aufnehmen möchte.
Maschinenbau in der Schwerpunktrichtung dann erneuerbare Energien.
Das habe ich dann aber aus persönlichen Gründen abgebrochen.
Ich war nicht so ganz mit dem Herz dahinter.
Ich habe erst zu dem Zeitpunkt festgestellt, wie das Handwerk eigentlich ins falsche Licht gerückt wurde in unserer Gesellschaft.
Und wir müssen eben auch verstehen, dass das nichts Niederes oder Minderwertiges ist.
Ja, sehe ich genauso.
Alter Schwede.
Wenn du dir die Preise heute mal anguckst.
Rein, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Aber wir haben überlebt.
Wir haben überlebt.
Die Anlage läuft wieder, alles richtig gemacht.
Und das, was dazwischen gekommen ist, das gehört eben dazu.
Seitdem ich eben in dieser neuen Position arbeite, sind das dann rund 4.500 Euro brutto im Grundgehalt.
Plus die entsprechenden Zulagen, die dann durch dieses Offshore-Leben eben entstehen.
Wenn wir uns jetzt beispielsweise mal den September anschauen, habe ich einen sehr guten Monat gehabt.
Durch diese Zulagen, die entstanden sind, komme ich also auf tatsächlich fast nichts.
Fast 8.000 Euro brutto.
Oh, da geht doch was.
Davon wird dann nochmal ein bisschen was abgezogen, um dann bei einem Nettobetrag von um die 4.800 Euro rauszukommen.
Das sind dann die Monate, die gut laufen.
Aber sowas musst du auch ordentlich bezahlen, sonst macht das keiner.
Ich sehe dann wirklich mal Bilder, wie Freunde sich im Kreis wieder treffen.
Und ich kann dann in dem Moment nicht dabei sein.
Das schmerzt tatsächlich schon sehr.
Es ist ein schöner Moment.
Zu wissen, dass wir gleich an Land sind.
Und dann wieder dem normalen Leben abgehen können.
Das ist der gute Tünnis.
Ich mag ihn tatsächlich sehr gerne, weil er immer wieder sehr hilfreich ist, weil man drinnen schlafen kann.
Und weil man ihn auch für den Urlaub nutzen kann.
Willkommen einmal zu Hause.
Wir haben hier eine sehr schöne offene Wohnung.
Das heißt einmal so einen sehr großen Wohnbereich.
Und es ist halt ein reiner Glücksgriff gewesen, in Hamburg sowas zu finden.
Wenn du jetzt deinem früheren Ich einen Rat mitgeben könntest, was wäre das?
Also es gibt eigentlich keine falsche Entscheidung, die ich getroffen habe für meinen beruflichen Werdegang.
Deswegen würde ich vielleicht den jungen Johann einmal ein bisschen beruhigen und sagen, dass du alles richtig machst.
Und dass du auf dem richtigen Weg bist.
Weil du wirst auf jeden Fall glücklich sein.
Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss.
Warte mal kurz, ich bin hier leiser.
Ah ja, du musst es auch ordentlich bezahlen, sonst macht den Kram ja keiner.
Ja, easy.
Okay.
Wenn ihr das Video schauen wollt, gibt es das einmal.
Das Abonnieren nicht vergessen.
Machen wir.
Ja, das war eine gute Folge.
Nein, nein, wir gucken uns jetzt nicht die Partnervermittlerin an.
Was zum...
Alter, was kriege ich da wieder für...
Alter, YouTube Shorts, Mann.
Jetzt habe ich einmal als Just for Fun so ein Video aufgemacht.
Jetzt kriege ich 24 Stunden Katzenschnurren vor Kamin.
Zeit für Shorts-Blocker.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, sowas gibt es, aber wenn ich mir das überlege, ja klar gibt es sowas.
Warum nicht?
Wollen wir noch ein bisschen durch Technik-Trends stöbern?
Ja.
Wie denn?
Wo denn?
Was meinst du jetzt?
Chatgear, hat irgendjemand Erfahrung von euch mit...
Also es gibt eine Fallout-Serie.
Es gibt eine Fallout-Serie.
Fällt mir gerade auf.
Wahrscheinlich Schrott, oder?
Wie das meiste andere, was da so verfilmt wird.
Niemand Erfahrung von euch mit Garmin-Power-Meter-Pedalen?
Ob das taugt?
Die sind Rotz?
Okay, warum?
Preis?
Ah ja.
Kram ist teuer.
Bei der Kurbel kommt es deutlich günstiger.
Ja, mag sein, ja.
Wieso 46 Euro mit Pedale?
Weil das noch ein Cadence und...
Ne, also wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Weil das ein Umdrehungs...
Wie viel Umdrehung-Minute du machst, Sensor eingebaut hat.
Und wie viel Leistung du trittst, Messung mit eingebaut hat.
Das ist das, was das teuer macht.
Die Pedale an sich wahrscheinlich weniger.
Wer ist du denn mit Klick-Pedalen?
Ich habe angefangen, ja.
Ich habe geübt auf meinem Trainer daheim.
Trittfrequenz, genau.
Mit Ein- und Ausklippen.
Ich fahre aber mit dem Mountainbike-Klipsystem.
Damit ich auch mal irgendwo zwei Meter laufen kann.
Ich habe aber kein E-Bike.
Ne, aber irgendjemand hat auch gesagt, das ist Schrott.
Ah ja, ich hatte zweimal ein Problem mit dem Kugellager.
Vielleicht aber auch...
Okay.
Hyundai liefert...
Hä?
Was zum...
Was hat das mit Pedalen zu tun?
Hast du das falsche Video gepostet?
Alter, ich habe kein E-Bike.
Es geht überhaupt nicht um ein E-Bike.
Wenn du sowas hast, dann brauchst du es nicht.
Ein ganz normales Fahrrad.
Guck, das hier ist das.
Was hat...
Die haben zwar die Pedale dran, aber es wird ohne Pedale geliefert.
Das ist kein E-Bike.
Und ich habe richtig Glück gehabt.
Guck mal, ich habe es 1.000 Euro günstiger bekommen.
Weil es das letzte Lieferbare war.
Ach ja, ich kann jetzt tatsächlich noch eine Sache hier dazu sagen.
Mein letztes Fahrrad hatte ja 1x11 Schaltung.
Und ich fand das ja mega nice, weil das so clean ausgesehen hat.
Kein Umwerfer vorne.
Nur ein Platt vorne.
Und insgesamt fand ich das ja super.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich bin jetzt ja schon zwei Runden mit dem neuen Fahrrad gefahren.
2x11 ist auch nicht verständlich.
Ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Ich habe gleich das automatische Schalten aktiviert.
Dass du quasi nicht mehr manuell umschalten musst vorne.
Sondern du kannst quasi nur hoch und runter schalten.
Und der macht das automatisch.
Das ist super angenehm.
Du merkst eigentlich kaum irgendwie einen großen Unterschied zu 1x11.
Und du hast auf dem Flachen, wenn es wirklich gute Straße ist, vielleicht ein bisschen bergab geht.
Noch ein bisschen mehr Tempo drauf.
Also es ist gar nicht so übel.
Automatik beim Rad, ja.
Das ist mit DI2 Schaltung.
Das ist elektronisch.
Normalerweise schaltest du...
Normalerweise ist es so.
Auf der Seite schaltest du hier vorne den Gang um.
Vom kleinen auf das große.
Oder vom großen auf das kleine.
Und auf der linken Seite hier schaltest du um.
Hinten.
Runter oder hoch.
Hattest du vorher auch schon DI2?
Ja.
Ich hatte 1x12 DI2.
Ich hatte exakt das gleiche Fahrrad.
Nur mit 1x12 DI2.
Versus jetzt 2x11 DI2.
Am liebsten hätte ich 1x12 gekauft.
Gibt es aber aktuell nicht.
Da hätte ich SRAM oder sowas nehmen müssen.
So und...
Man kann die Elektronik so einstellen.
Der 50 KMA...
So schnell war ich damit noch nicht.
Habe ich auch nicht vor.
Höchstens irgendwo wenn es richtig steil bergrunter geht.
Und jetzt kann man das so einstellen.
Das hat 3 Modi.
Wie man einstellen kann.
Hast du dein Fahrrad in Home Assistant?
Ne aber ich habe eine Home Assistant App.
Im Garmin.
Da kann ich theoretisch darüber Sachen steuern.
Zumindest...
Es gibt 3 verschiedene Shifting Modi.
Die du einstellen kannst.
Manuell.
Das ist so wie man es sich vorstellt.
Hier.
Hoch runter hinten.
Hoch runter vorne.
Und dann hast du Synchro Shift.
Heißt das.
Da kannst du einstellen.
Dass du nur hier schaltest.
Hoch und runter.
Und wenn du dann quasi angekommen bist.
Auf...
Hier auf dem Großen.
Da unten.
Und...
Ne Moment.
Da oben.
Dann schalte das dann 1 runter.
Und schalte hinten 3 auf.
Also du kannst quasi alle Gänge durchschalten.
Nur mit einem Hebel.
Und das vorne umwerfen passiert automatisch.
Das ist mega nice.
Ah das ist keine Federung.
Ne wozu?
Keine Federung.
Ich fahre ja keine Trails.
Oder irgendwelche abschüssigen Walddinger.
Oder so.
So.
Und...
Wollte ich jetzt noch sagen.
Ja also eine Sache werde ich aber tatsächlich da dran noch modifizieren.
Und zwar hinten ist zur Zeit eine 11-34 Kassette drauf.
Das heißt.
31 durch 34.
Der...
Der leichteste Gang.
Hat leichte...
Leichte Untersetzung.
Mehr oder weniger 1 zu 1 zu dem was mein Alters hatte.
Mein Alters hatte das kleinste glaube ich 42 zu 54.
Was zum...
Warum kann das Google jetzt nicht ausrechnen?
Eben konntest...
Eben...
Das kann Google ausrechnen.
Okay.
Ähm...
Kann man hier irgendwie...
Errechnen das Ergebnis?
Ja.
Also...
Das ist sogar ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen leichter jetzt.
Ja.
So.
Nicht ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
Was ich machen werde ist.
Ich werde hinten noch 40er Kassette drauf bauen.
11 bis...
11 bis 40.
Und dann komme ich easy jeden Berg hoch.
Das kostet...
Ja 2600 Euro.
Aber das ist super Preis.
Das ist ein Carbonrahmen.
Alles dabei.
Nice Schaltung.
Bremsen.
Nur keine Pedale.
Pedale sind nicht dabei.
Also bis jetzt bin ich echt zufrieden.
Ich bin aber auch erst 2 Runden gefahren.
Hätte ich das nicht gemacht.
Aber...
ich gehe damit auch nicht einkaufen ich benutze das rein zum fitness mäßigen fahren also das
weiteste was ich bisher gefahren wenn man glaube ich 62 kilometer aber das war ziemlich anstrengend
weil da ging es in ordentlichen berghoch wie gesagt deswegen will ich mir die pedale kaufen
damit misst man zwar nicht seine geschwindigkeit die katze ich ja auf meinem gps tracker aber da
kann man besser einschätzen wie viel leistungs output man hat ja das ist das würde ich nicht
mal ich habe zwar ein schloss dabei so ein ganz kleines leichtes was du mit jedem seitenschneider
gefühlt auf kriegst falls ich wirklich mal aus irgendwelchen gründen ganz kurz irgendwo
anhalten muss und weil ich ich wüsste nicht wozu ich es brauchen sollte aber ich habe so
ein kleines mini schloss dabei ich habe nicht vor dass ich brauche aber man weiß ja nie
okay was haben wir sonst noch hier auf youtube zu bieten heute das ist professionelles achter
kevin wieder von dem aber auch schon eine weile nichts mehr geguckt ist professionelles code
langweilig wahrscheinlich wie so vieles was man professionell macht ist der großteil langweilig
sonja hat gesagt es ist schon wieder outdated dass apple epic gebannt hat epic was an band
after a cream to normal mean tweets
ist ja was leute wir machen jetzt mal wir räumen mal kurz die tabs auf das könnte man
sich angucken das könnte man sich angucken das könnte man sich angucken das auch das
vielleicht auch die ui library ist das gucken wir uns nicht an gucken wir uns auch nicht an
gucken wir uns ist outdated hätten wir vor zwei wochen gucken müssen gucken wir uns auch nicht
an software entwickler sind immer schon vielleicht wenn es mir danach ist gucken
wir uns auch nicht anschauen wieso haben wir uns als software entwickler immer schon
nicht mehr an, gucken wir uns auch nicht mehr an, äh, was ist aus Battlebit geworden, vor
einem, das interessiert mich tatsächlich, ich glaube, das hatten immer so viele Spieler,
so, das gucken wir uns auch nicht an, Maurice wieder am Start, gucken wir uns jetzt auch
nicht mehr an, auch nicht mehr, GitLab was hacked with an image, haben wir das nicht
schon geguckt?
Nochmal Maurice, äh, Docker is one of my most, nein, gucken wir uns auch nicht mehr
an, heute geht es um Milliarden, der peinliche Absturz von LFTs, gucken wir uns auch nicht
mehr an, Monkeys, Albtraum Arbeitsplatz, Boreout, kaputt durch Unterforderung, okay,
das könnte man sich vielleicht angucken, das gucken wir auch nicht mehr, gucken wir
auch nicht mehr, gucken wir auch nicht mehr, der Auer,
was hat denn der, was hat denn der, der, der Bauer Neues, haben wir schon eine Weile
nicht mehr geguckt, bitte kauft sowas nicht, okay, warum?
Hallo zusammen, weil es Schrott ist, okay, aber eigentlich ist mir das egal, ich kaufe
mir sowas auch nicht, weil ich habe schon was, wie schädlich ist Social Media nun wirklich?
Guck mal hier, das ist mein Stream Deck, kommt drauf an, kommt drauf an, ob du das
falsche auf Twitter gepostet hast und deswegen Leute bei dir auf der Arbeit anrufen und
sagen, ich habe das nicht, ich habe das nicht, ich habe das nicht, ich habe das nicht,
ich habe das nicht, ich habe das nicht, ich habe das nicht, ich habe das nicht, ich habe
das nicht, ich habe das nicht, ich habe das nicht, ich habe das nicht, ich habe das nicht,
Das KeeperFX, haben wir auch schon geguckt, haben wir auch schon, Weihnachtszeit, das ist zu outdated, keine Ahnung, vielleicht, informatische Masse, haben wir nicht irgendwas, JavaScript, JavaScript Devs are switching to Rust, das ist auch, Alter,
das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, diese Überschrift schon wieder, man, okay, ich habe, wir haben ein bisschen, wir haben ein bisschen aufgeräumt, hat zumindest den Vorteil, dass ich jetzt wieder sehe, was, wenn ich neue Tabs aufmache, meint er geschlossene Wasserkühlung allgemein oder nur das Corsair Ding, keine Ahnung, was er meint, aber dass er das allgemein meint, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, er hat ja in der Vergangenheit auch schon Dinge von denen getestet und empfohlen,
also ich bin echt zufrieden damit, muss ich sagen.
Das ist ja mein, das ist ja mein allererster PC mit Wasserkühlung, ah, irgendwann ist es mal bei jedem so weit, den ich mir hier gekauft habe, letztes Jahr, und das Ding macht überhaupt keine Zinken, funktioniert wunderbar, ist auch nicht übertrieben laut, blubbert nix, wie viel RAM belegt dein Browser, erstaunlich wenig, guck mal, oh, 4 Gig, Chrome braucht mehr, 4 Gig, das ist halt nix,
ich hab, wie viel RAM hab ich, 64 Gig, kommt drauf an, was du haben willst, Wasserkühlung ist unterm Strich, wenn es dir wirklich um die Temperaturen geht oder um maximal Multicore-Takt oder was auch immer, ist besser als eine Luftkühlung, also vom, wie nennt man das, von der Kühlcharakteristik oder so, ich persönlich würde auch Luftkühlung vorziehen, einfach weil es simpler ist und ja, auf lange Sicht sicherlich auch wenige, wenige Fehlerquellen hat,
aber in dem Fall war es sinnvoll.
Und bis jetzt bin ich echt zufrieden mit, ob ich den nächsten PC wieder mit Wasserkühlung kaufe, weiß ich nicht, die Empfehlungen sind ja schon hart pepeger heute wieder, ähm, warum will das die ganze Zeit, dass ich dieses komische Sauna-Video gucke, oh Leute, ich muss mal kurz mein Headset entknoten, ich hab irgendwie noch 20 Zentimeter Kabel übrig, so, wieder am Start, lasst uns kein Interesse beim Sauna-Video angucken, das geht nicht, ich bin nicht eingeloggt, da kann man das nicht machen, leider.
Sätge, was ist das?
Die ist ausgewachsen, oder?
Ja.
Och, ist der niedlich, ja.
Der ist für uns niedlich.
Für die Mäuse oder was auch immer da so rumkrabbelt.
Ist das Furcht einflößt?
Wobei, Mäuse, ich weiß nicht, wenn das ein Blatt ist.
Was ist das für ein Blatt?
Er macht sich für.
In der Wartung.
Äh.
Wasser.
Junge Katzen sind aufgewachsen, um sich zu interessieren.
So lernen sie über ihren Welt.
Und hopp.
Neuer Jumper.
Auch wenn es sie in Probleme bringen kann.
Ja, was der jetzt jagt, würde mich auch mal interessieren.
Aber.
Oh, und hopp.
Ich dachte, wir sehen jetzt noch, was der fängt.
Ne, darf man nicht sehen, das ist quasi nur ein Teaser dafür gewesen, oder was?
Sieht irgendwie nicht echt aus.
Ja, bestimmt.
Und garantiert AI-generated Content gewesen.
Wisst ihr, was ich bei solchen alten Katzenvideos immer sad finde, wenn ich sehe, 16 Jahre, dass es die wahrscheinlich nicht mehr gibt?
Da fragt man sich echt, was die sich so erzählen.
Klassiker.
Ja, das Video ist schade.
Was auch Klassiker-Video ist, kennt ihr bestimmt noch alle, oder?
Charlie bit my finger.
Gibt es das auch mit Meme-Untertiteln?
Wahrscheinlich.
Jetzt habe ich leider YouTube auf die falsche Fährte gelockt.
Jetzt habe ich mir drei Kassenvideos angeguckt.
Und jetzt denkt sich YouTube, nope, jetzt musst du immer mehr.
Das ist ein Sauna-Video, Mann.
Mir hätte es zu.
Ja, das ist das erste YouTube-Video gewesen.
Oh, das ist die Excel-Schubserin.
Also ganz ehrlich, die YouTube-Empfehlungen heute sind mal richtig ganz für den Arsch.
Ich gucke.
Ich gucke das Sauna-Video nicht.
Keine Chance.
Dann gucke ich mir lieber an.
Live-Office-Zoomer.
Ich kenne den Channel nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das was taugt.
Okay.
Entschuldigung.
Wenn es zu cringe und unlustig ist, mache ich aus.
Stubenmocker 500.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, was sonst morgens?
Sub, Bro.
What's up, Mate?
Finally, you here.
You bringing some main character vibes by always coming too late.
I know, I know.
I was busy grinding this morning.
Whatever.
Let's go to school.
Alright, everybody.
This next video will show how maths work.
Listen carefully.
Pick maths.
And then go ahead and try it out.
So like I said, the first step is just going through any of these and just scrolling to
find any products that we can possibly work with.
So let's say this product right here is what I want to add to my list.
Was bin ich da eigentlich sehend?
Kommt da jetzt so irgendwas?
Why aren't you watching the video I put up, Brandon?
It's not interesting enough to me.
I'll learn it at home.
You're supposed to learn it at home.
Kommt da jetzt so irgendwas?
Why aren't you watching the video I put up, Brandon?
It's not interesting enough to me.
I'll learn it at home.
You're supposed to learn it at school and only do the homework at home.
It's not interesting enough to me.
I'll learn it at home.
You're supposed to learn it at school and only do the homework at home.
Okay boomer.
Excuse me, do you not understand how important these lectures are?
I'll manage myself.
I usually watch this material on YouTube.
These YouTube teachers explain it much better.
Then why are you here?
I keep wondering myself that as well.
I know I'll never use this lecture in the future.
I'd rather not use it in the future.
Das ist das richtige
Crime-Set-Mindset.
Sagt der Boomer
oder Broomer?
Ey, ich glaube, das Video ist nicht für mich.
Ich bin selber
nicht Gen-C genug
dafür, glaube ich.
Okay, YouTube.
Ich versuche, YouTube jetzt zu erklären,
dass ich das Sauna-Video nicht gucken will.
Ich klicke das jetzt an.
Zwei Sekunden View-Time und ich mache
wieder zu. Meistens bringt das
YouTube dazu.
Nein.
Keine Chance.
Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, YouTube lernt es jetzt.
Und?
Kein Sauna-Video mehr.
Jawohl. Ist geschafft. Easy.
Sauna-Video
outdated,
overrated, jebaited.
Okay. Das können wir uns jetzt noch angucken.
Ab jetzt kommen mehr Sauna-Videos.
Ich hab's angeklickt.
Was ist das denn sonst noch so?
Professionelles Coden.
Ist das langweilig?
Zeig mal hier.
Er ist nicht mehr in Spanien.
Das letzte Mal, wo ich ein Video von ihm geguckt hab,
da war er in Spanien.
Und hat dort von irgendeinem
Ferienhaus oder so, remote Home-Office...
Moment.
Ist das der,
mit dem Dackel, der Franz heißt.
Das habe ich mir irgendwie gemerkt. Ja, oder?
Franz.
Ich glaube schon.
Franz, Alter.
Using Docker in unusual
ways. Das habe ich eben offen gehabt.
Und dann habe ich es wieder
geclosed, weil ich mir gedacht
habe, das ist wahrscheinlich
nichts. As a time machine, running legacy
code, hosting a local stack,
integration testing,
improving application security. Easy.
Das machen wir doch alles schon.
Ich meine, wir sind
errorless driven programmers.
Bei uns geht alles immer first try.
Dementsprechend können wir auch auf wirkliche Kommentare
und Tests und solche Sachen verzichten.
Einfach
fehlerfrei programmieren. Okay, kommen wir es mal an.
Ist professionelles Coden
langweilig?
Hi Leute, heute gebe ich dir wieder
einen Einblick in den Arbeitsalltag
eines Softwareentwicklers.
Ich mache den Job schon seit über
10 Jahren.
Diesen Begriff
habe ich in letzter Zeit auch öfters gehört.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das bedeuten
soll. Shift left.
Ich habe das schon öfters gehört. Ich habe
null Plan, was die Leute damit meinen. Kann mich
irgendjemand mal aufklären?
Oder der
Metminister weiß das bestimmt. Oder
der benutzt das.
Nein, nein, die meinen bestimmt nicht das. Shift left.
Verantwortung für ein
Thema nach links an den Anfang schieben.
Geht darum, Security schon ab der
Entwicklung zu integrieren, nicht
erst ganz am Ende.
Teil von DevSecOps. Und warum
heißt es Shift left?
Das ist ja
ein äußerst unintuitives
Buzzword.
Zurück auf Anfang.
In der Timeline.
Ach so, weil du in der
Timeline nach left shiftest.
Es gibt so viel
Schwachsinnsbegriffe.
Ich habe übrigens
es gibt in jedem Unternehmensverband
daneben so ein paar Begriffe, die sich
dort durchgesetzt haben, weil
mal irgendwelche Manager-Dudes
das die ganze Zeit verwendet haben.
Zum Beispiel in der alten Firma, wo ich
gearbeitet habe, war das
Next Level. Irgendeiner
bei unseren Manager-Leuten damals
hat diesen Begriff laufend
verwendet. Für jeden Scheiß. Dann müssen wir
das Next Level erreichen. Next Level hier,
Next Level da und sowas.
Das hat sich so durchgesetzt, dass auch die
ganzen anderen Manager-Dudes, die cool
sein wollten, Next Level als Wort verwendet
haben. Und irgendwann haben sogar
alle anderen Leute angefangen,
jeden Scheiß irgendwie Next Level zu nennen.
Wobei das oftmals dann
so eher
so ironisch gemeint war.
Also nach dem Motto, das ist ja richtig Next Level.
Zumindest haben dort gefühlt alle Next Level
gesagt. Jetzt in der
aktuellen Firma, wo ich bin,
ist mir aufgefallen, dass dort ganz viele Leute,
wenn es Wartungsarbeiten
gibt, also stellt euch
mal vor, es gibt Wartungsarbeiten,
ein System wird
abgelöst durch das andere.
Und das passiert jetzt
nicht von heute auf morgen,
sondern Einzelsysteme
der Reihe nach.
Und da habe ich jetzt schon
öfters den Begriff gehört,
wir machen dort keinen
Big Bang.
Das klingt so komisch,
Alter.
Wir machen keinen Big Bang.
Das habe ich jetzt schon öfters dort gehört.
Das ist garantiert auch
irgend so ein Wort, was
irgendwelche Manager-Dudes dort schon seit
Jahren, seit Jahren
benutzen. Und
das hat sich da jetzt irgendwie durchgesetzt.
Kein
Big Bang. Cutover.
Ja,
es gibt überall so
Dinger, die sich da durchgesetzt haben.
Aber wir diagonal skalieren
ja nur, da kann uns das nicht passieren.
Da müssen wir uns doch sinken, ja.
Ich würde sagen, in unserem Daily Stand-Up
machen wir das dann. Aber ich kann
dir jetzt schon sagen, wir sind damit hoch,
hochdruckt ran an dem Thema.
Also, gucken wir mal.
Arbeiter aktuell bei einem TV-Streaming-Anbieter.
Neue Funktionen.
Ja, Dings, bei Vaipu arbeitet er, gell?
Wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich will er es nicht mehr so prominent sagen.
Vielleicht haben die sich ja aufgeregt darüber.
Zu entwickeln ist ein großer Teil
des Aufgabenbereichs, aber es gibt noch so viel mehr.
8.30 Uhr Arbeit zu beginnen.
Ich fange meistens 7.30 Uhr tatsächlich schon an.
Weil, da kann ich früher abhauen.
Easy.
Also, einen Softwarefehler
in einer App oder in einem...
Videospiel gefunden.
Also, irgendetwas hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Solche Programmfehler können immer mal...
Was hat er denn da eigentlich offen?
Mit was machen hier die Mac-Hackermans
Hackermans-Stellstelle? Ist das Xcode oder was ist das?
Softwarefehler in einer App oder in einem
Videospiel gefunden. Also, irgendetwas
hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Solche Programmfehler können immer mal wieder
auftreten und da muss man sich auch einfach mal
hinsetzen und diese Probleme lösen.
Für heute habe ich mir deshalb vorgenommen...
Was war denn das?
...eine ganze...
Ah, so ein Spezial-Kaffee-Kaffee-Kaffee-Mach-Ding.
Gut, ich trinke keinen Kaffee, fällt flach.
...und diese Probleme lösen.
Für heute habe ich mir deshalb vorgenommen,
eine ganze Reihe von Bugs zu beheben.
Ich zeige dir also, wie man solche Bugs findet,
das Problem identifiziert und den Fehler behebt.
Siehste?
Der hat nicht das Wubbler-Stream-Diplom.
Dann wirst du das fehlerfrei programmieren,
alle Probleme löst.
So, ich meine, wann...
Chatgear, seriously.
Wann hat schon mal irgendwas...
Wenn wir hier programmiert haben,
im Stream nicht funktioniert.
Never, oder?
First try, fehlerfrei.
Immer.
Und wir wissen auch,
dass das hier gar keine richtigen Issues sind,
sondern einfach nur Anwendungsfehler.
Oder Anwenderfehler.
Und in Kombination mit diagonaler Skalierung,
dann ist Quality wirklich Destiny, ja.
Wenn wir gleich noch sehen,
dass seine Variable nicht Cakeweight oder Tempogas heißt,
na, nee, nee.
Das ist...
Plupp lasse ich mir auch noch gefallen.
Aber richtige Variablen-Namen sind schon ziemlich...
Outdated.
Bevor ich loslege, haue ich mir allerdings mein Frühstück rein
und werfe...
Wow, super gesund, Alter.
Da soll ich mir mal eine Scheibe von abschneiden.
Das ist relativ lang, weshalb ich einfach mal von oben anfange.
Nummer 1, der unsichtbare Bug.
Bei iOS und Android gibt es jeweils Systeme,
die sich darum kümmern,
dass eine App nicht zu viel Arbeitsspeicher verbraucht.
Wenn eine App dennoch nicht genug mit Ressourcen umgeht,
kann es sein, dass sie einfach geschlossen wird.
Also unter Linux dann sowas wie der OOM-Killer.
Aktuell haben wir ein Problem,
dass der Speicher nicht mehr freigegeben wird,
wenn wir in der App umschalten.
Das heißt, jedes Mal wird ein neuer Screen erzeugt,
aber nicht aus dem Speicher geworfen,
wenn er nicht mehr benötigt wird.
Ich habe in meiner Entwicklungsumgebung Xcode,
also das Programm, mit dem ich iOS-Apps programmiere,
verschiedene Diagnosetools, um die Ursache dafür zu finden.
Manchmal ist es offensichtlich,
aber hier war es schon ein wenig verständlich,
dass man sich die Verbindung versteckt.
Ich kann mir alle Objekte,
die sich aktuell im Speicher befinden, mit diesen...
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da sehe,
aber es sieht sehr advanced aus.
...diesen Memory Debugger anschauen.
Ah!
Das sieht man...
Ne, wobei...
Also, ich kann das hier null zuordnen,
was, was, was, was man da sieht.
Gut, ich kenne Xcode auch nicht.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Unreal Blueprints,
aber auch nicht wirklich.
Man kann sich die Verbindungen zwischen diesen einzelnen...
Okay, aber...
Also, ich gette, was er sagt,
aber ich kann das nicht in Zusammenhang bringen
mit dem, was ich sehe.
...Objekten ganz gut darstellen lassen,
was natürlich dabei hilft,
solche Retain-Cycles zu finden.
Das erkennt man dann ganz gut,
wenn man so eine zyklische Verbindung
zwischen mehreren Objekten...
Ach so!
Ah, verstehe.
Okay, das ist natürlich nice.
...Objekten hat.
Sieht man auch hier, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Ich gehe hier auch nicht zu sehr in technische Details,
aber mit ein paar kleinen Änderungen des Codes
konnte ich das Problem...
Was ist denn das für eine Sprache?
Ist das...
Else?
Ist das schon mal nicht Go?
Das ist Swift?
Swift?
Ja.
Das war jetzt auch nur geraten,
weil ich dachte, es sieht nicht aus wie was,
was ich groß kenne,
aber es ist Apple, also habe ich jetzt mal
auf Swift getippt.
Also es ist definitiv nicht Objective-C,
also so viele Möglichkeiten gab es da gar nicht.
Was? Guard?
Was ist Guard?
Wo steht Guard?
Chatgear?
Ich sehe es noch nicht mal.
Unter Item?
Ach hier, Guard, Item.
Ist das irgendein Multi-Threading-Gedöns?
Nee.
Das ist quasi ein If.
Aber warum kann man nicht schreiben,
If item is cancelled,
return,
warum schreibt man Guard Item not cancelled,
else return?
Na gut.
Ich hätte jetzt vielleicht wegen Guard
irgendwas Multi-Threading-mäßiges gedacht,
aber keine Ahnung.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt mal.
Guard, Swift.
Swift Guard Statement.
In Swift,
we use the Guard Statement
to transfer program control out of scope
when certain conditions are not met.
Okay, das ist quasi ein If, oder?
Ein If? Ah ja.
The Guard Statement is similar to the If Statement
with one, ich kann nicht mehr sprechen,
with one major difference.
The If Statement runs
when a certain condition is met,
while the Guard Statement runs when a certain is not met.
Äh, Ausrufezeichen?
Fragezeichen?
Warum brauche ich dafür eine extra, hä?
Okay,
just Apple things.
Kann auch Spaß machen,
denn im Prinzip ist es wie eine Detektivarbeit.
Vor allem, wenn man den Fehler
selbst nicht reproduzieren kann,
wird es oft kompliziert.
Aber mit genügend Erfahrung und Konzentration
kommt man schon mal irgendwann mal auf die Lösung.
Um 10.30 Uhr haben wir wie jeden Tag
unser Daily Meeting.
Das ist so eine kurze Abstimmung,
um sicherzustellen, dass jede Person
an den richtigen Aufgaben arbeitet.
Ich habe da also einfach mitgeteilt,
dass ich mich heute ausschließlich um neue Bugs kümmere.
Deshalb können wir direkt mit dem nächsten Bug weitermachen.
Ja, ich finde es witzig,
wir haben unser Daily,
ein bisschen früher,
aber auch so in dem Dreh.
Und nachdem es 10.45 Uhr ist bei ihm,
tippe ich drauf,
dass das Daily bei denen auch nur für eine Viertelstunde
angesetzt ist.
Wir arbeiten aktuell an einem neuen Design
für unsere Aufnahmen.
Das heißt, in unserer App kann man einzelne Sendungen
und Serien aufnehmen.
In der Gesamtübersicht haben wir oben solche Filter,
um die Liste, naja, zu filtern.
Wenn ich auf eine Serie tippe,
dann wollen wir, dass der ausgewählte Filter
für die Unterseite auch übernommen wird.
Funktioniert das aktuell noch nicht.
Im Prinzip sollen die Filter also immer
synchronisiert werden, egal in welche Richtung.
Das heißt, wenn ich den Filter auf der Unterseite ändere,
dann soll sich diese Änderung auch
auf die Hauptseite auswirken.
Die Lösung ging jetzt relativ einfach,
denn wir benutzen für jede Seite
eine unterschiedliche Datenquelle.
Was ich aber machen kann, ist, dass das Attribut,
wo der aktuelle Filter gespeichert wird,
über alle Datenquellen geteilt wird.
Wenn man den Filter also an einer Stelle ändert,
wird sich das automatisch
auf alle anderen Seiten auswirken.
Also, globale Variable
klingt so negativ,
globaler State klingt nicht so negativ.
So mal die Idee.
Meine Code-Änderungen sind jetzt natürlich nicht final,
denn wie in jedem professionellen Umfeld
machen wir auch hier Code-Reviews.
Das heißt, ich mache einen Pull-Request auf,
in dem all meine Änderungen übersichtlich dargestellt werden.
Mein Kollege schaut sich dann alles
detailliert durch und gibt Verbesserungsvorschläge.
Und dann sagt er agree-ge.
Wenn dann alles passt und nur dann
können meine Änderungen in die eigentliche App
gebracht werden.
Lass mich in den Kommentaren wissen,
falls du zu diesem ganzen Workflow
ein eigenes Video sehen möchtest.
Naja, jetzt ist erstmal Pause angesagt
und in der Mittagspause gehe ich erstmal
eine Runde mit Franz spazieren.
Das tut auch mir gut,
damit ich mal ein bisschen frisch...
Moment, Chat, Chat,
ihr habt prinzipiell das Wichtigste vergessen.
LGTM ist schon okay,
aber ohne Rakete geht da nix.
Rakete muss sein.
Wenn man mal im Flow ist,
das passiert mir auch manchmal.
Der hat's gut, Mann!
Der kann den ganzen Tag wenigstens was Sinnvolles machen
und muss nicht 75% mieten.
Aber es bringt mir immer neue Energie,
wenn ich mal ein bisschen draußen an der Luft bin.
Und dann, Franz bekommt seinen Mittagessen.
Wie definierst du globale Variablen
in .NET Projects?
Ich mach immer eine Public Class mit Content-Variablen.
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an,
was man machen will.
Das kannst du natürlich machen.
Die App Settings und
Dependency Injection,
wenn's ein bisschen größeres .NET Projekt ist.
Du hast irgendeine globale,
keine globale, Blödsinn, was laber ich denn?
Irgendeine App Settings
Klasse, wo dann so
Dinger drinstehen wie, keine Ahnung,
welcher Username ist in der
Config eingetragen oder kommt über
Environment-Variablen irgendwas rein.
Und die registrierst du in deiner
Dependency Injection.
Eventuell auch über Options.
Das ist ja neu.
Da gibt's ein paar Sachen.
Die kannst du
sogar mittlerweile
automatisch refreshen
lassen, wenn sich was an der
JSON-Datei geändert hat.
Und das
kannst du dann in deinem Dependency Injection
registrierst du das.
Und dann lässt du dir
einfach eine Instanz
App Settings oder App Config
oder halt was auch immer du brauchst injecten.
Und du kannst dann gleich einbauen,
dass der sich das zusammenbaut.
Aus den richtigen Quellen.
Zum Beispiel, vielleicht hast du
die Möglichkeit, das über eine
Config-File zu setzen, über
Environment-Variablen zu setzen,
über Command-Line-Switch zu setzen.
Und da musst du nicht jedes Mal gucken,
ist Command-Line gesetzt, ist
Environment-Variable gesetzt.
Das kann diese Option-Geschichte für dich machen.
Dann klickst du in Option-Class rein.
Das ist dann keine globale
geshared State
Klasse in dem Sinn.
Das ist meistens so transient.
Also du kriegst dann
pro Anforderung eine neue Instanz davon.
Ja, wenn du
globale Variablen brauchst,
hätte mir jetzt eigentlich
grad nichts ein,
wo ich so richtig global
übergreifend mal irgendwas gebraucht habe.
Also wenn du eine Datenbank hast, dann ist es meistens eh
relativ easy. Geht das erst in die Datenbank rein.
Auf der anderen Seite wird es gequeried.
Aber
also sagen wir mal so, es gibt
schon sicherlich die ein oder anderen Sachen,
die eben global einzigartig sind.
Ja sowas wie Konsolen-Output und sowas vielleicht
in der Richtung.
Oder sagen wir mal schreiben.
Sagen wir mal, okay, ich habe eine Idee.
Sagen wir mal, du hast eine Klasse,
die schreibt irgendwie
Serial-Port irgendwas oder USB
und so. Ja.
Dann würde ich in meinem
Dependency-Injection irgendein Singleton
registrieren, was ich mir injecten lassen kann.
Und dann habe ich meinen globalen State,
aber trotzdem über DI.
So würde ich das wahrscheinlich machen. Hängt immer ein bisschen
vom Anwendungszweck ab.
Injected in einen Kaffee, ja.
Das klingt spannend. Wir haben das sogar, haben wir
das nicht sogar letztens im Stream hier gemacht?
Mit Options
injecten? Also das ist,
das ist ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich easy.
Du kannst,
vielleicht machen wir das dann nächstes Mal.
Kann ich erst mal zeigen. Wollen wir ein bisschen basteln.
Erinnere mich beim nächsten
Blogger-Stream dran, dass ich dir das zeige.
So, kommen wir weiter.
... und ich hau mir ne...
Oh, ist das... Ich hätte jetzt erst mal gedacht,
es ist so eine Art Lasagne,
aber doch nicht. Eine leckere Lasagne.
Doch, Lasagne. Okay, okay, an ein paar Stellen
ist noch der Wurm drin, aber deshalb
kümmern wir uns heute ja um alles.
Denn ich habe euch ja schon die Serienaufnahmen gezeigt
und da haben wir aktuell noch das Problem... Sturm der Liebe, ah.
... dass wir nicht den einzelnen... Serien,
Serien-Enjoyer. ... Episodentitel anzeigen,
sondern den Seriennamen.
Das ist natürlich offensichtlich Quatsch, denn die sind
in der Formation, bringt hier überhaupt keinen Mehrwert.
Deshalb werde ich das Ganze jetzt spezifischer
gestalten. Jede einzelne Episode
einer Serie soll sich jetzt den
Episodentitel holen und diesen dort
anzeigen. Auch hier wieder ne sehr kleine
Aufgabe. Chatgear ist doch klar, was er
meint. Aber irgendwann muss man das mal
repariert haben. Aktuell ist das jetzt noch gar
nicht so schlimm, weil unsere iOS-Kunden
diese Neuerungen noch gar nicht sehen. Das heißt,
aktuell gibt es diese neuen Funktionen
noch gar nicht, aber spätestens, wenn
wir das Ganze ausrollen, sollte alles
funktionieren und Sinn ergeben. Für solche
Fälle haben wir auch Tester in der Firma, die sich
die App immer mal wieder genauer anschauen und
solche Fehler notieren, damit... Siehste?
Nächster Vorteil von immer
first try fehlerfrei programmieren. Du brauchst keine
Tester zu bezahlen. ... wir sie dann in der Zukunft
reparieren können. Sobald du mal
mit der Softwareentwicklung zu tun hattest, dann
wirst du auch wissen, dass es in der Programmierung
immer viele Lösungen für das gleiche
Problem gibt. Und deshalb ist die Absprache
mit anderen Entwicklern so super wichtig,
um eine gemachte Änderung...
Warum kümmert er sich denn um
Design-Entscheidungen? Wahrscheinlich, weil das keine
riesen Team ist. Wahrscheinlich
machen die nicht für alles Konzeptzeichnungen
oder sowas.
Auf der anderen Seite...
Weiß nicht, wie es da aufgeht, aber ich finde, das ist doch eigentlich
gut, oder? Wenn ein Programmierer
ein gewisses Auge für, was sinnvoll ist
und was nicht sinnvoll ist, im Interface
hat, finde ich das sogar gut.
Ist doch nice. Ich finde das auch immer
gut, wenn Entwickler über den Tellerrand rausgucken
und wenn Admins über den Tellerrand rausgucken
oder jeder. Letztendlich profitieren
da alle nur von. Ja, wenn
Entwickler sich ein bisschen Gedanken drüber machen, zum Beispiel
worauf am Ende oder wie ihre
Software dann deployed wird und läuft
und umgedreht bei der
Infrastruktur sich auch ein bisschen Gedanken
drüber gemacht wird. Okay, wie wird hier Software entwickelt?
Wie können wir es den Leuten einfach machen,
neue Sachen zu testen?
Zu besprechen habe ich jetzt einen
Call mit einem Kollegen. Ich möchte
einfach mal seine Meinung zu ein paar Ideen
haben, wie ich die Bugs bisher gefixt habe.
Wie gesagt, wenn man die Köpfe zusammensteckt,
dann kommt man oft schneller auf eine bessere Lösung.
Und weiter geht's. Hier haben wir
jetzt ein visuelles Problem, denn wir haben
auf der Übersichtsseite die Möglichkeit
vorgeschlagene Sendungsempfehlungen
direkt in die persönliche Bibliothek aufzunehmen.
Naja, jetzt haben wir hier allerdings
noch einen sehr unschönen Glitch.
Wenn man den Button gedrückt hat, dann zeigen
wir den Ladespinner an, weil wir erst noch
den Request abschicken müssen. Oh, ich
sehe es schon. Und dann
blitzt kurz aufnehmen durch.
Und wenn der Ladevorgang abgeschlossen
ist, wird für einen sehr kurzen Moment
noch der alte Status angezeigt.
Also, echt.
Da musst du Optimistic updaten.
Da schickst du den, oder wie man das nennt,
da schickst du den, ne,
Chat, also da wäre ich auch pingelig.
Finde ich auch nicht, dass
das, also das würde mir persönlich
schon so gegen den Strich gehen, dass ich das auch
fixen wollte. Das wird
wahrscheinlich kaum jemand groß
stören, aber es ist auf jeden Fall unschön.
Ja, das wird auch nicht meinem
persönlichen Ordnungsempfinden
entsprechen.
Bei sowas musst du die Sachen
quasi, wie nennt sich
das, Optimistic Update oder so? Da gibt's
auch so ein komisches Buzzword für. Also
sprich, du schickst den Request los,
so nach dem Motto, okay,
der User klickt jetzt auf aufnehmen.
Du schickst den Request los und bevor du den
Request überhaupt fertig hast und der Server
sagt, jawohl, ich hab's umgestellt, stellst du
einfach den Button schon um. Sollte der Server
aus irgendwelchen Gründen tatsächlich einen
Fehler melden, stellst du ihn wieder zurück.
Ist nicht schön. Ich muss erst mal herausfinden,
woran das liegt. Im Prinzip
lag es jetzt daran, dass wir mehrere Requests
an den Server checken. Also, natürlich
der erste Request und wenn ich auf den Button drauf
drücke, um zu sagen, ich möchte
das jetzt in meine Liste aufnehmen
und dann müssen wir noch auf einen zweiten Request
warten, damit sich die ganze Liste
aktualisiert, damit das neue Element auch
dargestellt wird. Wir haben allerdings den
Spinner schon zurückgesetzt, bevor
der zweite Request abgeschlossen
wurde. Aber das funktioniert jetzt auch schon
super, deshalb würde ich sagen, dass wir direkt
mal zum letzten Bug für heute gehen.
Dieser Fehler ist, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ein bisschen
cool. Okay, da bin ich
seit einer halben Stunde meistens
schon nicht mehr
am Rechner oder spätestens
ab 16 Uhr nicht mehr am Rechner.
Ich gehe dann meistens noch
mal eine Runde draußen mal
frische Luft schnappen und dann setze ich mich wieder
vor den Rechner, wie sich das so Kellerkind-mäßig gehört
und spiele MMO
Kreiselcrime bis 22 Uhr
oder mache Stream oder Youtube
oder irgendwas. Youtube müsste ich auch mal wieder
machen. Schon irgendwie seit über einem Monat
kein Video am Start.
Komisch, denn auf der Übersichtsseite
steht bei manchen Serien, dass
wir zum Beispiel zwei Aufnahmen für die einzelne
Serie haben, aber sobald wir
auf die Serie drauf tippen, sehen
wir allerdings nur eine Episode.
Absolut merkwürdig.
Zuerst ist es tatsächlich in der Android-App
aufgefallen, aber nach einer Analyse
haben wir bemerkt, dass wir genau das gleiche
Problem auch in der iPhone-App haben.
Der Fehler lag schließlich darin, dass wir
zu viele Filteroptionen an unser Backend
schicken, wenn wir nach der tatsächlichen Episodenliste
fragen. Immer hydrated sein.
Deshalb steht auf der ersten Seite, dass es
zwei Episoden gibt, aber nach einer
weiteren Filterung wird uns nur ein Ergebnis
angezeigt. Das heißt, den überflüssigen
Filter aus dem API-Request
entfernen und schon bekommen wir
alle Episoden. Auch hier mache ich natürlich
wieder meinen Pull-Request auf. Mein Kollege kann
sich die Coin-Änderung anschauen und am
nächsten Tag werde ich dann alles mal durchgehen
und gucken, was er für Feedback gegeben hat.
Naja, jetzt haben wir 17.30 Uhr.
Wir haben heute vier Bugs platt gemacht,
also gar nicht mal so schlecht, oder?
Zusammenpacken und ab nach Hause.
Nachdem ich Feierabend mache... Moment!
Das ist nicht bei ihm zu Hause?
Das ist auf der Arbeit?
Nee, im Leben nicht.
Das ist einfach sein Arbeitsplatz.
Gar nicht mal so schlecht, oder?
Das ist quasi sein Büro
sozusagen daheim.
... und ab nach Hause. Nachdem ich Feierabend mache,
verbringe ich natürlich noch ein bisschen Zeit mit meinem Sohn,
aber sobald er schläft, wird es auch für uns
endlich Zeit, die Beine hochzulegen
und zu chillen. Mit einem Teller voller
Sushi... Excel!
Das würde ich mir jetzt...
Da würde ich sogar auf Nudeln mit
Lachs verzichten oder auf Nudeln mit
Tomatensauce heute. So eine ordentliche
Portion Sushi würde ich mir
jetzt auch reinhauen.
Im Teller voller Sushi wird noch ein bisschen Netflix
geschaut, bevor ich dann um halb zehn
ins Bett gehe.
Das war's und ich hoffe, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Dein Kevin.
Hi Leute, heute gebe ich dir wieder einen Einblick in...
Sag dir mal, ich gehe früh ins Bett.
Max, wie ist dein Büro
eingerichtet auf der Arbeit?
Naja, gut, nachdem ich nur einen Tag die Woche in Frankfurt bin,
ist da nicht sonderlich viel gemacht.
Nagischer Schreibtisch,
Monitor drauf, Docking Station,
fertig.
Was ich mitbringe ist, also es gibt
theoretisch ein Headset auf der Arbeit,
das benutze ich aber nicht. Ich benutze immer mein
Noise Cancelling Kopfhörer.
Ja, und...
Stellenausschreiben müssen wir echt mal wieder
machen. Ja, hast du recht. Vielleicht,
vielleicht heute Mittag.
Worum es Kreiselcrime-technisch
geht. Ich schreibe mir das mal auf. Müssen wir echt mal
wieder machen, ja. Richtig.
Ja, aber ansonsten, wie gesagt,
schön verstellbarer Schreibtisch, ziemlich
schlechter Stuhl im Vergleich zu meinem hier,
äh, großer Bildschirm drauf,
Docking Station, das war's, mehr habe ich nicht.
Auf der Arbeit.
Ja, viele bei uns anderen
haben die Sachen super customised im
Büro, also mit Bildern und allem.
Ich nicht. Nagischer Schreibtisch, gutes.
Wir ziehen aber bald auch um ins
Großraumbüro. Der Trend
ist zwar schon wieder abgefahren, aber bis das
in Deutschland ankommt, dauert das immer ein bisschen.
Ich freue mich da aber
tatsächlich drauf, weil dort ist
meistens nicht viel los, weil die meisten Leute
Homeoffice-Stells machen.
Und ich sitze mit anderen Linux-Leuten zusammen
im Büro, die nicht in meinem Team sind.
Da habe ich, das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Ist auch mein Kollege wieder dabei, mit dem
ich gewechselt bin von der alten Arbeit zur neuen.
Wir haben uns schon die
Plätze so klar gemacht, dass wir quasi
daneben hocken, so. Dass wir quasi zusammen
in der Ecke hocken. Ich habe ein
Bose QuietComfort
35 oder so
heißt das. Das habe ich seit ein paar
Jahren schon. Sicherlich nicht mehr
aktuellster Stand der Technik,
aber ganz okay.
Was habe ich hier eigentlich für komische
Bilder drinne, Mann, als
Emotes?
Billy posing with his cute waifus.
Alles klar.
Ja, ich finde es auch nicht schlecht.
Ich finde es auch nicht schlecht. Ich freue mich da drauf.
Ja.
Musste jetzt auf Jabra umsteigen. Warum?
Ich habe ein Jabra
Headset auf der Arbeit, so ein einseitiges.
Das benutze ich gar nicht.
Stimmt, wo ist der Chainlawer, wenn man
den braucht? Wobei, brauchen wir den?
Ja, aber warum musstest du umsteigen?
Also ich benutze absichtlich das hier.
Gucken, wie das aussieht.
Ah, das ist so ein beidseitiges. Okay,
dann schauen wir mal besser. Ah ja, okay,
es suckt. Also das funzt.
Aber ich benutze das auch immer übers
Handy, ja. Ich mache Teams
auf der Arbeit nur übers Handy und
join auf dem Desktop nur rein, wenn ich was sharen muss.
Decked Headset.
Aus welchem Jahr kommt
ihr denn? Okay, bisschen random
die Frage.
Von Nixielaner.
Bisschen random die Frage, aber du warst doch
früher auch Turnschuher. Ja, ich habe
meine Ausbildung gemacht bei einem Internetprovider
mit mehreren Standorten
in Deutschland und
Rechenzentren weltweit.
Wie hast du da den Weg zum Jetzt gemacht?
Ich bilde mir ein, dass ich dazu schon einige
Videos habe auf YouTube,
aber ich bin mir nicht
sicher, ob ich jemals ein,
wie nennt man das so,
Werdegang-Video gemacht habe.
Was haltet ihr? Findet ihr das eine gute
Videoidee? Habe ich glaube ich
noch nie so komplett gemacht. Okay,
du bist ja momentan mehr im DevOps-Bereich
oder was machst du derzeit? Ja.
Ja, habe ich zwar nicht mehr. Bei der
alten Arbeit hatte ich das offiziell
in der Berufsbezeichnung. Habe ich nicht mehr.
Ich bin jetzt Senior
Linux-Engineer, aber letztendlich ist das
eh alles Schall und Rauch. Die
Arbeit ist gar nicht so großartig unterschiedlich.
Hast du vorher schon
programmiert? Bin erzertert, wenn du mich gerade
ein bisschen zu verändern.
Ja, habe ich.
Ja.
Also ich habe 2002
oder so angefangen
zu programmieren.
Und da war
ich auch schon 18.
Ja.
Vorher ein bisschen
in der einen
Schule, aber
da hat es bei mir noch nicht gezündet.
Das lag aber auch daran, der Lehrer hat gesagt und
irgendwelche Low-Level-C-Sachen zum Einstieg
gemacht. Wahrscheinlich eher 2001,
wo ich angefangen habe. Ich habe mir damals
ein Python-Buch gekauft, 2001.
Das war damals so der
neueste Scheiß. Das war noch Python 2,
2, 4
oder sowas. Also ich
habe schon immer ganz gerne programmiert. Also immer,
aber schon lange. Ich habe schon lange gerne programmiert.
Bin erzertert,
wenn ich überlebe, mich gerade ein bisschen zu verändern.
Also du hast, wenn du dich fürs
entwickeln
von Software interessierst, plus
Background hast im Admin-Linux
Umfeld oder auch Windows Umfeld, hast du
optimale Voraussetzungen für...
Ich weiß ja nicht, was du gerade
vorhast. Also ich kann dir
sagen, wie das bei mir war.
Ich habe eine Ausbildung
gemacht beim Internet
Provider. Danach
war ich da noch ein Jahr.
Allerdings, ich war ja
also der Provider kam nicht aus Frankfurt,
aber ich war ein Frankfurter Standort.
Und wir haben uns dort
für eine Bank
um das Rechenzentrum gekümmert
und um die Linux-Server von denen,
um den Betrieb von der ganzen Geschichte.
Wir waren da quasi
hinverkauft, wenn du es so willst.
Und
irgendwann, und da habe ich ja schon ein Video zu gemacht,
deswegen, das muss ich nicht.
Da gab es jetzt ja...
Gibt es da ein Video von?
Hier.
Wenn der Chef dich verarscht.
Da habe ich ein Video zu gemacht, was da alles
gelaufen ist auf der
Internetseite.
Damals, nach der Ausbildung.
Zumindest, ich habe da noch ein Jahr oder zwei.
Ich weiß es jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht mehr so genau.
Ich habe doch meinen Lebenslauf hier irgendwo. Sekunde, warte mal.
Office?
Ne.
Lebenslauf.
Libre Office.
Lass mich gerade mal in meinen Lebenslauf gucken.
Dann kann ich es dir sagen. Also.
Ich kack noob, habe ich das... Ah doch, hier.
Siehst du, ich habe es geschickt gemacht.
Ich fange von oben nach unten an.
Also, Ausbildung beim Provider.
Als Physi.
Danach, eineinhalb Jahre ungefähr,
habe ich dort noch gearbeitet.
Hast du nicht die Notepad-Skill-Liste
als Bewerbung geschickt?
Doch, habe ich dabei geschickt.
So, und...
Danach hatte ich Glück.
Die Bank, wo wir damals
uns um das Rechenzentrum gekümmert
haben und um die Lernungs-Server,
die haben gesagt, sie wollen ein bisschen unabhängiger von Dienstleistern
werden. Habt ihr nicht Bock
zu uns zu kommen? Und da war ich
natürlich sofort dabei und habe gesagt, ja, easy.
Wo muss ich unterschreiben?
Weil es hieß damals, besserer Laden
und mehr Kohle
auf einen Schlag.
Ja, easy mache ich sofort.
Zumal mir, wie gesagt, wen es genau interessiert,
kann sich das Video angucken, was ich gerade gezeigt habe.
Der Provider extrem
auf den Sack ging.
Da hatte ich überhaupt keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Bin ich dann dahin gewechselt
und...
Also, ich war da von Anfang an quasi auch im
Linux-Team.
Ich habe aber privat auch schon
immer gerne Sachen gebastelt und
entwickelt und programmiert und
Microcontroller-Zeug und alles mögliche
von Command-Line-Tools.
Ich habe Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen, Web-Anwendungen.
Also, was wir hier im Stream auch machen. Wir haben ja hier im Stream
gefühlt alles schon mal
irgendwie gemacht. Mich interessiert da auch vieles.
So, und
dann haben wir irgendwann angefangen mit
Server-Automatisierung, war es damals.
Falls noch jemand Puppet
kennt. Kennt jemand Puppet?
Kennt das noch jemand?
Verwendet heute kaum noch jemand.
Außer die Leute, die Legacy
Sachen
noch supporten müssen.
Zum Verteilen von Updates,
nee, ist es nicht. Puppet ist
eine Config-Management-Software.
Dort stellst du zum Beispiel ein,
da stellst du zum Beispiel ein,
ich will auf einem Linux-System
einen Ordner haben,
var lib
blub und der soll 7.7.5
als Rechte haben.
So, und das...
Das ist kein YAML, glaube ich, oder?
Das ist, glaube ich, so ein komisches
komischer Dialekt.
Das ist quasi der Vorgänger von Ansible.
Nicht wirklich der Vorgänger von Ansible.
Weil es hat mit Ansible
nichts zu tun.
Aber es ist auf
Ruby-Basis.
Aber es ist die gleiche
Richtung an
Software, ja.
Ja, genau so sieht es dann aus.
Du willst einen Pfeil anlegen, NTP-Conf,
unter diesem Pfad,
Content soll hierher kommen,
Owner das und so.
Also es ist ein bisschen wie Ansible, nur halt nicht Ansible.
Hat übrigens ein paar coole Sachen,
die Ansible nicht hat, aber dafür ist Ansible
insgesamt viel angenehmer zu
benutzen, ja. Zum Beispiel hat Puppet
einen ordentlichen No-Op-Mode,
wo man sieht, was er machen würde.
Er ist zwar auch nicht ganz perfekt, weil manche Sachen
siehst du erst, wenn er es wirklich machen würde.
Aber...
Das ist ganz cool.
Wo liegt der Vorteil gegenüber einem Bash-
Skript? Ja, im Bash-Skript musst du alles
ja auch komplett selbst machen.
Wenn du ein bisschen mehr brauchst, als einfach nur
Datei anlegen. Natürlich, unter der Haube
könntest du auch ein Bash-Skript machen und sagen, hier
Touch oder
mkdir touch und dann
chmod oder sowas, ja, kannst du auch machen.
Aber spätestens, wenn du Abhängigkeiten
untereinander hast,
wenn es parallel vielleicht sogar
ausgeführt werden kann, dass es schneller geht, weil du
viele Sachen konfigurieren musst,
wenn du was komplizierteres
machen möchtest, als nur Dateien anlegen,
ja, zum Beispiel in
ssh-config irgendwelche
Options ausschalten, dann artet das
mit Bash-Skripts aus. Mein Bash-Skript ist das, wie du es
früher gemacht hast. Zumal
auch die ganze Sache drumherum, ja,
das Ausrollen zentral
mit Bash-Skript viel komplizierter ist.
Aber in kleineren, also man
muss die Sache ja nicht verkomplizieren.
Wenn du nicht viele Systeme hast,
wenn es nicht so sonderlich
kompliziert ist, was du drauf machen willst, kannst
du einfach ein Bash-Skript basteln.
Also man muss nicht, ich bin immer
dafür, das pragmatisch zu handhaben.
Sensible und Puppet, das macht Sinn,
ab einer gewissen Größe, vor allem ab einer gewissen
Systemanzahl.
Ansonsten,
mal ein Bash-Skript.
Wenn es was kleines ist, ja.
Mach ein Bash-Skript, was nach Cloud-Init läuft,
fertig. So, und
worauf habe ich jetzt eigentlich geantwortet?
Random, irgendwas mit random kam da.
Genau.
So, und
damit haben wir damals angefangen, Serverautomatik,
und irgendwie,
wir haben angefangen
mit SVN, das war noch
in dem SVN drin,
und irgendwie
habe ich mal ein Video geguckt,
wo es um
Softwareverwaltung
und Versionsverwaltung mit Git ging.
Das war damals noch ganz neu,
2011,
oder so, und
dann habe ich mich wirklich
monatelang mit
der Source-Code-Verwaltung auseinandergesetzt
und mit Git-Workflows
und wie man am besten
was branched und wie macht das der
Linux-Kernel eigentlich.
Und dann habe ich angefangen,
unsere
Serverautomatisierung,
wir hatten damals tatsächlich noch
Githooks, ja. Ich habe einen Githook
programmiert, der beim Pushen gecheckt hat,
ob die Leute Syntax-Fehler in ihren Puppet-Files
haben und sowas. Da habe ich mit
angefangen. Das war quasi schon
DevOps zu Zeiten, wo es kein Wort
dafür gab.
So, und
nachdem ich das ja quasi in der Firma
mit erfunden habe, diesen ganzen
Workflow und alles,
als es dann irgendwann mal
darum ging, als man festgestellt hat,
das ist ja durchaus sinnvoll,
dass man sich darum kümmert, und das ist
auch ein guter Ansatz, quasi
DevOps-Pionier, ja, wenn du so willst.
Das ist ein guter Ansatz.
Dann habe ich das auch
als hauptsächliche Aufgabe
gekriegt. Und da habe ich
mich auch jahrelang darum gekümmert,
quasi automatisches
Ausrollen von Config-Updates.
Teilweise kamen da sogar noch Versions-
Updates für Software mit dabei,
die da mit ausgerollt wurde.
Und wir hatten
zwischenzeitlich, war ich federführend
verantwortlich für
knapp 4000 Linux-Systeme,
dass die einmal im Monat
die neuesten Updates und
Config-Sachen bekommen.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass
immer alles perfekt gelaufen ist,
aber wir hatten nie
große Ausfälle
dadurch. Wurde PAPA
dann auch für Container-Deployments benutzt?
Ne.
Also wir hatten nie größere Ausfälle
dadurch. Es gab da sicherlich
immer mal die ein oder anderen Probleme.
Das Ganze ist dann so gewachsen,
und am Ende sah das, also ich habe das dann auch
immer weiter ausgebaut, am Ende sah das
so aus, dass wir tatsächlich das ähnlich
hatten zu dem, was da Kevin gerade im Video gezeigt
hat. Wir hatten übrigens
eine GitLab ganz am Anfang, als es
noch neu war,
habe ich eine GitLab installiert, da
zwischenzeitlich hatten wir Bitbucket, weil die Firma sagte
Atlassian muss, wir wollen alles von
Atlassian haben, und
mittlerweile sind sie
bei GitHub
gelandet. Naja,
zumindest lief das dann
auch so, dass wir hatten ein Team,
also das Linux-Team war
relativ groß, da waren glaube ich 17 Leute am Ende,
für alle möglichen
Anwendungen, verschiedene
spezifische Sachen, wo sich die Leute ausgekannt haben,
lief das dann so drauf raus, dass
wir auch so einen Merge Request
Workflow hatten, also sprich, mal
angenommen, die Leute, die sich um die Loadbalancer
gekümmert haben, mussten irgendwas an,
die hatten da zum größten Teil HA-Proxy
am Start, mussten irgendwas an der HA-Proxy
Config ändern, und das sollte
natürlich dann möglichst
automatisiert auf alle, frag mich nicht,
30 Loadbalancer-Kisten
ausgerollt werden. Das lief
dann so, die haben das bei sich gemacht,
die haben sich einen Branch aufgemacht, ich habe da so
einen Guide geschrieben, damals zu,
wie das aussehen soll,
und das hat sich tatsächlich,
also, wenn man sich das mal
überlegt, dass wir damit angefangen haben,
bevor das großartig etabliert
war,
kam da was relativ Gutes bei raus,
was so heute eigentlich mehr oder weniger
viele machen. Also,
zum Beispiel war es so,
wenn mal angenommen, Leute, die für HA-Proxy
zuständig waren, wollten was in ihre Config ändern,
die haben sich einen eigenen Branch
ausgecheckt,
Vorgabe von mir war, Branch soll
heißen, Kürzel
slash Feature-Name,
das hieß dann zum Beispiel, was weiß ich,
ABC, wenn das da ein Namenskürzel ist,
ABC slash
neues Feature,
da haben die sich ausgecheckt,
haben die Sachen entwickelt für ihre HA-Proxy,
für ihre Loadbalancer, haben das
in der Bastelumgebung
getestet, konntest ja einfach
die Server umstellen auf den neuen Branch,
haben das ausgeführt,
haben festgestellt, okay,
Puppetechnisch, Automatisierungstechnisch,
macht das alles, dann
sind die ins,
was auch immer zum damaligen Zeitpunkt aktuell war,
ich sag mal GitLab, reingegangen,
haben ein Pull-Request aufgemacht,
beziehungsweise Merch-Request aufgemacht,
dort musste dann
drinnen stehen, eine Ticketnummer
vorne, Feature-Name
und wie kritisch
sie das Ganze einschätzen, das war für mich
immer recht wichtig zu wissen,
sobald es nämlich Service-Unterbrechungen gab,
bei irgendeinem Change oder bei irgendwelchen
Änderungen, musste man das im Vorfeld ankündigen,
deswegen war immer gut, wenn die Leute
von sich aus schon mal eine Einschätzung geschrieben haben,
ey, da wird was neu gestartet
oder nicht,
kurze Beschreibung rein, fertig, Abflug,
dann habe ich nochmal einen Blick
reingeworfen, wie das Ganze
aussieht, ich hatte zwar von den
meisten Sachen Server-Technisch
wenig Ahnung, aber es gab
so die üblichen Verdächtigen, was die Leute
oftmals vergessen haben,
von
Domains, die falsch waren,
von Server-Namen,
wo was vertauscht war, von Schreibfehler,
ich habe da tatsächlich relativ oft was gefunden,
was noch nicht gepasst hat,
dann ging das halt nochmal zurück,
die haben das gefixt, wieder gepusht,
dann wurde das Ganze gemerged und einmal im Monat
gab es dann halt quasi einen Tag drauf
und das kam dann zuerst nochmal
zentral ausgerollt
in die Testing-Umgebung,
dann in die nächste, dann in die Abnahme-
Umgebung, dann irgendwann live.
So.
Da habe ich mich bis zum Schluss drum gekümmert
und da bin ich quasi mehr oder weniger
so reingewachsen in diese
Rolle
und als es mir dann zu
sehr auf den Keks ging, in der Bank
wo ich gearbeitet habe, mein letzter Arbeitgeber,
habe ich eine Liste erstellt,
drei Seiten mit Skills,
einen ordentlichen Lebenslauf
zusammengebastelt
und mich umgeguckt
und jetzt
bin ich in dem neuen Laden gelandet.
Natürlich nicht ganz
random so, sondern ich hatte
Glück, dass
mich jemand, den ich noch von früher kannte,
unter anderem da, von diesem Arbeitgeber,
wo ich vorher gearbeitet habe,
hat gesagt, Max, du, ich habe gehört,
du suchst einen neuen Job, willst du nicht zu uns?
Und dann
ging das Ganze recht schnell, ich habe den
schon mal unter der Hand, meinen Lebenslauf und
die Skill-Liste geschickt, die hat er
seinem Chef weitergeleitet, sein Chef hat mich
angerufen, noch bevor offizielle
Bewerbung raus war.
Ja.
Er hat beim Bauhaus Weihnachtsbaum kaufen,
weiß ich noch, hat mich angerufen.
Und
ja, das ging schnell, weil die Kündigung
musste ja bis Ende des Jahres raus, letztes Jahr.
Äh, nicht
letztes Jahr,
vorletztes, vorletztes Jahr.
Ja, und dann bin ich da
gelandet, wo ich jetzt gelandet bin.
So, das war jetzt
die mittellange
Kurzfassung.
Die Recruiting-Prämie geteilt,
nee, haben wir nicht. Er hat die Recruiting-Prämie
für mich bekommen und ich habe die Recruiting-Prämie
für meinen anderen Kollegen bekommen.
Weil ich habe ja noch einen mitgebracht,
das ist ja gerade das Witzige dabei.
Ich habe die Bewerbungsunterlage von
meinem Kollege mitgenommen
und habe gesagt,
nachdem mein Vorstellungsgespräch
fertig war, habe ich gemeint,
ich habe gesehen, ihr sucht noch einen zweiten
Linux-Kenner.
Ich kenne da noch
jemand, habe ich ihm die Bewerbung
in die Hand gedrückt und zwei Tage später
hatte der auch einen Anruf und konnte dann auch da anfangen.
Und das war auch der Nagel in den
Sarg für die alte Firma,
weil wir hatten dann im Endeffekt
einen neuen
Arbeitgeber mit guter Homeoffice-Regelung,
ähnlich guter Anbindung,
wie gesagt, 800 Meter Luftlinie vom alten Laden
weg, das ist der neue,
genauso gute Anbindung, gute Homeoffice-Regel,
ordentliche
Kohle,
insgesamt
einen deutlich besseren Eindruck gemacht
und mein Kollege konnte sogar noch mitkommen.
Also das war wirklich so der letzte Nagel,
in den Sarg für die Bank.
Und ja, dann sind wir
1.4. zur Versicherung gewechselt, letztes Jahr.
So sieht das aus.
Hat dir das was gebracht,
was ich dir erzählt habe jetzt,
Nixielaner?
Gibt es bei euch dann auch GIT-Schulungen,
als das neu war?
Ich habe beim alten Laden
ein paar GIT-Schulungen gemacht,
als das neu war.
Was war eigentlich deine ursprüngliche Stellenbezeichnung,
als du bei der Bank angefangen hast?
Äh, weiß ich gar nicht.
Wahrscheinlich Linux-Server-Admin
oder so.
Glaube ich.
Ich kann mal gucken.
Ich habe irgendwo mein Zeugnis noch.
Von damals.
Zeugnis?
Keine Ahnung, finde ich jetzt gerade auf dem zweiten Rechner nicht.
Ich glaube Linux-Server-Admin
oder sowas.
Muss das gewesen sein.
Ja.
Später war ich offiziell Senior DevOps-Engineer.
Ich meine, passt so.
Ich habe damit zu einer Zeit angefangen,
wo es das Wort noch nicht gab.
Und jetzt bin ich Senior Linux-Engineer.
Letztendlich ist mir der Name aber vollkommen wurscht.
Wichtig ist das, was gemacht wird.
Auf Jobbezeichnungen
kannst du eh nix geben.
Ich wäre eher für Fifehead-Engineer,
aber das checkt dort wieder keiner.
So.
So sieht's aus.
Jetzt PepoFed
und danach Stellenanzeigen.
Ich glaube, es ist echt PepoFed-Time.
Ja.
Es ist 13 Uhr.
Wartet mal, ich check mal was.
Wartet mal, lasst mich mal kurz was gucken.
Ich bin mir nämlich unschlüssig,
ob ich nachher noch eine Runde Fahrrad fahren soll oder nicht.
Das Wetter ist okay,
aber jetzt nicht so geil,
wie es angekündigt war.
Vielleicht machen wir nachher wirklich Stellenanzeigen.
Ich habe nicht die Programmierskills,
die du hast.
Die hatte ich auch nicht von Anfang an. Hat niemand.
Ich mache natürlich Bash und so Skripte
hier für Datenverarbeitung, aber ich glaube,
da muss ich noch reinhängen.
Wir arbeiten viel mit Linux,
da würde ich auch gerne wieder hin.
Ja, sehr gute Entscheidung.
Linux ist auch gefragt.
Potenziell würde ich tatsächlich sagen,
das ist aber wirklich sehr subjektiv,
ich kann das nicht mit Statistiken untermauern.
Potenziell würde ich sagen,
verdienst du als Linux-Admin mehr als Windows-Admin.
Nur bezahlen die hier nicht so gut wie bei euch.
Ja, gut.
Frankfurt Finanzbranche, ich habe doch letztens erst
gesagt,
eine der Top-Branchen in Deutschland ist glaube ich
Banken auf der 1,
Versicherungen auf der 2,
Pharmaindustrie auf der 3
und Autos auf der 4
oder Autos auf 3 und Pharmaindustrie auf 4,
irgendwie so.
Also Banken und Versicherungen sind Top 2.
Ja, ist halt so.
Manchmal hat es auch seinen Vorteil,
wenn man in Frankfurt oder Frankfurt und Umgebung wohnt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Liest sich immer gut.
Aber,
wir haben so 200 Server,
je nachdem wie viele Leute ihr seid
und was da drauf...
Also, wenn du dich in Richtung DevOps-Bereich
weiterentwickeln willst,
es ist jetzt nicht zwingend erforderlich,
dass du der super krasse Programmierstelzer bist
oder so,
aber du musst dich natürlich schon mit ein paar Sachen beschäftigen,
die oft in den Bereich fallen.
Zum Beispiel Automatisierungen
aller Art,
sei es jetzt auf Betriebssystem-Ebene
Automatisierung, aber auch Build-Pipelines,
Infrastruktur-Automatisierung
für irgendwelche
Cloud-Setups
und du musst...
Also wenn du in dem Bereich die üblichen Tools,
guck dir mal Ansible an,
guck dir Terraform an,
guck dir einen der großen 3 Cloud-Anbieter
ein bisschen im Detail an.
Es ist jetzt eigentlich fast egal,
ob das Azure, Google oder Amazon ist.
Und ansonsten,
es schadet auf jeden Fall nicht
noch
die Programmiersprache,
sich ein bisschen tiefer anzugucken.
Im Cloud- und DevOps-Umfeld
generell ist Go sehr beliebt,
weil viele der Tools dort,
was Cloud angeht,
in Go selbst programmiert sind.
Go ist auch eine gute Einsteigerprogrammiersprache,
aber wenn du unter Linux unterwegs bist,
ist es eigentlich fast egal,
da kannst du alles verwenden.
Du kannst Csharp.net machen,
du kannst Go machen,
du kannst Java machen,
du kannst Python machen,
damit zu beschäftigen
und ein paar kleine
Bastelprojekte zu haben,
ist nicht verkehrt.
Es hilft einem,
oder meinetwegen auch Perl,
wobei, man muss ein bisschen
masochistisch veranlagt sein.
Okay, da hat einer aufgepasst im Stream,
das heißt nicht Cloud-Anbieter,
das heißt Hyperscaler, korrekt.
Also Go wäre auch nicht verkehrt,
tatsächlich.
Also eine Programmiersprache gut können
ist immer von Vorteil,
unabhängig davon,
in welchem Bereich du unterwegs bist.
Ich bin der Meinung, es bringt immer was.
Es hat auch einen Vorteil,
ganz ehrlich, wisst ihr,
was auch ein weiterer Vorteil ist?
Es gibt doch schon seit jeher
immer so ein bisschen so Gezanke
zwischen der Admin-Seite
und der Entwickler-Seite.
Das ist normal.
Die Entwickler erzählen dir dann irgendwie
nach dem Motto, so schwierig kann es doch nicht sein
und erzählen dir dann irgendwie,
ah, wer hat denn den Mist wieder programmiert?
Das ist ja eigentlich schon Standard.
Warum machst du schiss dich bei Perl?
Weil Perl outdated, overrated,
debated ist.
Und wenn du selbst allerdings
halbwegs brauchbar programmieren kannst,
dann merken Entwickler das relativ schnell
und reden mit dir normal.
Und wenn du dann mit denen
auch normal redest,
auch als Admin,
dann versteht man sich
und die Intergroup-Communication
klappt deutlich besser.
Also die Erfahrung
habe ich schon gemacht, ja.
Ich arbeite relativ viel mit einem ehemaligen
Java-Entwickler zusammen, jetzt in dem aktuellen Projekt,
wo ich bin.
Und wir haben uns schon öfters über irgendwelche Entwicklungen
unterhalten, was Programmieren mäßig angeht.
Ich habe ihn nach irgendwelchen Garbage-Collector-Runs
gefragt und sowas.
Und das funzt
einfach manchmal
besser, wenn man ein bisschen Ahnung
vom Programmieren hat.
Das ist so, das ist so, ja.
Ich versuche ja auch immer so ein bisschen dafür
Werbung zu machen, dass es für alle Seiten gut ist,
wenn sie ein bisschen über den Tellerrand rausgucken.
Entwickler, die nur stumpf
ihre IDE kennen
und nix drumherum, sind halt total
schnell aufgeschmissen, zum Beispiel
so nach dem Motto, ey,
ich will das jetzt nicht auf meiner lokalen Admin-Kiste
testen, ich will das jetzt im Kubernetes-Cluster testen
und gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Wie tunnel ich mich da in die
Dings? Wie melde ich mich da an?
Wie mache ich ein Deployment-Yaml?
Die wollen das oftmals auch gar nicht machen,
weil die sagen, das ist ja kein Entwickler-Job.
Und umgedreht hast du dann
irgendwelche Admins,
die sich darüber aufregen, warum das
so kacke entwickelt wurde, dass es sich nicht
gescheit vercontainerisieren lässt und sowas.
Ist halt Blödsinn.
Am besten ist, wenn beide
von beidem Ahnung haben.
Natürlich ein gewisser Schwerpunkt.
Ihr wisst, ich programmiere viel.
Wir haben im Stream auch schon viele Sachen programmiert.
Ich bin aber kein professioneller Software-Entwickler,
der damit sein Geld verdient. Aber ich kenn mich gut genug,
dass ich da
wie sagt man im Stream?
Die Pain-Points
halbwegs nachvollziehen kann
bei den meisten Sachen.
Und das führt dazu, zumindest habe ich den Eindruck,
dass gerade auch unsere Architekten
und Entwickler
geneigter sind, sich dann auch
um die andere Seite
Gedanken zu machen.
Bist du Admin hauptberuflich?
Ja, wenn du so willst schon. Ich bin Senior Linux Engineer.
Nein, ich bin kein Admin.
Im Prinzip ist es aber sowas.
Ja, klar.
Die ganzen DevOps-Leute sind Admins.
Oder waren mal Entwickler zum Admin
montiert.
Man nennt sich heute nur DevOps Engineer,
weil es einfach cooler klingt als Admin.
A real talk,
Freunde.
Ja, die Aufgaben sind schon
ein bisschen übergreifender als in der klassischen
Admin-Rolle. Aber ich hab's schon oft gesagt,
die Job-Bezeichnung macht
es ist eigentlich wurscht, was da draufsteht.
Es ist cool, wenn du
gewisse Level hast, wenn da Senior
davorsteht. Das macht sich im Lebenslauf gut.
Aber ob du Admin bist,
DevOps Engineer bist, Linux Engineer
bist, was auch immer.
Letztendlich
ist wichtig, was du machst am Ende.
Wo du landest und was du da machst.
Nicht so sehr, was auf deinem
Titel draufsteht oder auf deinem Job draufsteht.
Also ganz ehrlich, aus dem DevOps-Bereich
sind mir deutlich mehr
Admin-Leute bekannt als Entwickler,
die sich dahin orientiert haben.
Das wächst immer mehr zusammen.
Das sag ich ja auch, wenn es um
Ausbildungsdiskussionen geht, dass es
immer mehr Überschneidungen gibt. Guckt mal.
Nehmen wir mal wirklich was ganz
aktuelles.
Mal angenommen, ihr wollt
eigentlich ist egal was,
ihr wollt irgendeinen Service entwickeln
und ihr lasst ihr
bei irgendeinem Cloud-Anbieter
als Cloud-Function laufen.
Wo hört dort das
Entwickeln auf und wo fängt das
Administrieren an? Könnt ihr da irgendeine
klare Linie ziehen? Also ich nicht.
Ist das Deployment für
Cloud-Functions eher noch was für einen Entwickler?
Ist das schon eher was für den Admin?
Ist das Ganze vielleicht generell
eine reine Entwickler-Sache? Weil es ist ja
so easy, du kannst quasi
programmieren, deployen, ausführen.
Wer kümmert sich aber darum, um zu
gucken, was das Ganze
kostet? Wer kümmert sich darum zu gucken,
wie sind die Response-Zeiten?
Wer überwacht das Ganze?
Es ist
gerade im Cloud-Umfeld super schwammig.
Wo das anfängt. Deswegen würde ich
sagen, macht es
eigentlich gar nicht mehr so viel Sinn.
Die Finanzabteilung macht...
Ja, ist klar, die Finanzabteilung macht
Kostenauswertungen von
irgendwelchen Cloud-Infrastrukturen.
Mit was machen die das? Mit Excel
oder wie?
Excel mit
AWS Connect
oder... Ne, so habe ich das
nicht gemeint. Was ich gesagt
habe ist, viele Leute, die ursprünglich
aus klassischen Admin-Jobs kommen,
sind heute eher
in dem Bereich unterwegs. Also ich kenne
im DevOps-Bereich mehr
ehemalige Admins als
ehemalige Entwickler.
Ja, da kann man sich auch drüber streiten.
Also Deployment ist für mich
das Schieben
der fertigen Software
auf das System, auf dem es läuft.
Das ist für mich
Deployment.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass das angestoßen
wird durch den Git-Push
in den richtigen Branch,
aber im Hintergrund passiert ja noch was.
Durch ein pures Git-Push kommt ja nicht ein Software-Update
auf den Server.
Da müssen ja noch irgendwelche Pipelines,
irgendwelche automatisierten Prozesse
oder auch manuelle Prozesse laufen,
dass sie darauf rauskommen. Und das Ding ist halt,
bei irgendeiner Cloud-Function,
da ist das halt
schwer zu sagen,
wo das anfängt und wo das aufhört.
Deswegen ist gut, wenn
beide Seiten von
allem ein bisschen Ahnung haben.
Ja, genau.
Was hältst du von nicht technischem Beruf
in der Infanzarbeit?
Noch keine Gedanken zugemacht.
Und ich finde es halt
auch irgendwie wichtig,
weil ich es schon oft erlebt habe,
dass man nicht immer denkt,
die anderen sind blöd
und seine Sache ist das Beste.
Ich meine, diese Auseinandersetzung
zwischen Entwicklung und den Leuten,
die es dann im Endeffekt betreiben müssen,
die ist ja so alt, wie es das gibt.
Ich finde das bescheuert.
Man selbst hat oftmals gar nicht
so sehr die Ahnung, was es
eigentlich alles für Probleme
drumherum gibt,
beim Programmieren, beim Entwickeln,
beim Entwerfen der Software,
weil man das halt einfach nicht kennt.
Man sieht halt oftmals nur das fertige Produkt
und Entwickler haben halt oftmals nicht so den Einblick
darauf, okay, wie kompliziert ist es
wirklich, den Kram 24-7
High Available zu betreiben.
Deswegen rutscht dann halt
ein Entwickler oftmals raus, so nachdem
man sagt, ey, warum habe ich kein Login
in die Live-Umgebung
oder warum geht das nicht?
Und du als Admin sagst dann mal relativ schnell
so nach dem Motto, Alter, warum ist das schon wieder
verbuggt, das kann ich auch.
Da muss man sich ein bisschen entspannen
und
erstmal davon ausgehen,
dass die anderen schon so
halbwegs wissen, was sie so treiben.
Und wenn man dann noch ein bisschen Ahnung
hat von dem, was der jeweils andere macht,
dann kommt man auch gut miteinander aus.
Ich finde, das ist eh die Zukunft.
Ganz ehrlich,
reiner Entwickler, der nur seine IDE
kennt, nichts drum herum, ist outdated.
Und reiner klassischer
Keller-Admin,
der
alles
Kacke findet, ablehnt
und was nicht seit
30 Jahren etabliert ist, ist bloated Müll,
ist auch outdated.
Leute, die in beide Richtungen
oder nicht nur in beide, in alle Richtungen
ein bisschen über den Tellerrand rausgucken,
sich für mehrere Sachen interessieren,
zwar nach wie vor ihren Schwerpunkt haben,
das ist das, was du heute brauchst.
Machen bei euch
das Deployment die Entwickler selber oder wie ist das
bei euch aufgeteilt?
Also, das kommt ein bisschen nach
Projekt und ein bisschen nach
Infrastruktur an.
Ich rede jetzt mal nur von dem Projekt,
in dem ich bin, wo die ganzen Sachen
hauptsächlich in der Cloud laufen.
Die Entwickler
entwickeln auf irgendeiner eigenen Kiste,
wo sie Admin-Rechte drauf haben,
und basteln können,
was das Zeug hält.
Da können sie auch lokal,
kann man das Deploy nennen,
lokal den Kram hinschieben, ausprobieren,
machen was sie wollen.
Dann können sie die Sachen
relativ unproblematisch
mit einem GitLab CI Job
in die
Entwicklungsumgebung in der Cloud
schieben
und dort ihre Sachen ausprobieren.
Da müssen sie sich allerdings ein bisschen
mit der Infrastruktur auseinandersetzen,
damit du dich gegen die Cloud
authentifizieren musst und auch ein paar
Tunnel zum Weiterleiten brauchst,
dass du da drauf kommst.
Da habe ich beispielsweise die letzten Wochen
viel mit einem unserer Entwickler
rumgebastelt, wie er aus IntelliJ
den Debugger an einen
laufenden Container
im Kubernetes Cluster
attachen kann.
Abenteuerliche SSH-Tunnel-Aktion,
ich kann euch sagen,
bis das funktioniert hat.
Das können die selbst machen
und
alles weitere
können die Entwickler nicht mehr
selbst machen. Also die Entwickler können nicht
in die Tests und in die Live-Umgebung
irgendwas hinschieben.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Entwickler, Entwicklerkisten ohne
Adminrechte sind scheiße. Da kriegst du
bei allem irgendwelche Zustände.
Wir hatten mal was, da wollte
sich ein Entwickler die Google
Cloud Tools installieren
und dann konnte er das
nicht. Das war noch die alte,
das war noch irgendwie so eine nicht privilegierte
Kiste. Und da wollte sich die
Google Cloud Tools installieren und da ging das nicht.
Und das ging auf
mehrere Ebenen nicht. Es war so, es war
also
damit, damit er Google
Cloud Tools auf diesem Rechner
installieren konnte, musstest du
wartet mal kurz, so
ähm
damit du die Google Cloud Tools installieren konntest
auf der Kiste, musstest du,
den Installer patchen.
Der Installer läuft nämlich über
den integrierten Python Runtime,
der Google Cloud Tools Installer,
der nicht unserem
Man-in-the-Middle Zertifikat vertraut hat,
weil diese Kiste dürfte nur über irgendeinen
Man-in-the-Middle SSH HTTPS
nicht SSH, äh HTTPS
Proxy raus ins Internet.
Da musstest du quasi die Installer
Runtime von dem Python vom Installer
patchen, dass er das installieren konnte.
Super abenteuerlicher Geschiss, aber
glücklicherweise haben die Entwickler mittlerweile
Admin-Entwickler
Entwicklerkisten.
Weil alles andere kannst du komplett vergessen.
Es ist nicht, es ist einfach, und ich hoffe
das haben sie jetzt auch soweit gecheckt,
es ist einfach unsinnig, nicht richtig möglich
ordentlich zu entwickeln und auch mal
ein paar Sachen auszuprobieren auf einer Nicht-Admin-Kiste.
Dass die Admin-Kiste jetzt dann keinen Zugriff
auf die produktive Umgebung braucht, ist was anderes,
aber die sollte ordentlichen Internetzugang
haben und
vielleicht über Proxy, meinetwegen aber dann ordentlich
eingerichtet, Internetzugriff haben
und die Leute sollten dort Möglichkeiten haben, was zu installieren.
Alles andere ist einfach nur Arbeitsverweidungsmaßnahmen
Deluxe.
So Leute, ich geh jetzt was futtern
und höchstwahrscheinlich, weil das Wetter ist
gar nicht so nice gerade, höchstwahrscheinlich
wenn man später eine Runde Stellenanzeigen
stellt.
PepoFatTime! Bis denn!
Hapa Hapa, ich geh jetzt was essen.
See you!